This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Scenti Mental. Acquare the competences essential
这是一个IHeart播客。保证真实。您是否有意愿去帮助并做出真正的改变？LaCite学院为您提供“依赖与心理健康”课程。获取必要的技能，
for accompany and support the people confronted to the difficulties of health and of dependence. Construise a career enrichisance
以陪伴和支持那些面临健康和依赖困难的人们。建立一份充实的职业，
to service of the community francophone of all the country. Donnay of Coney. It's possible
服务于全国的法语社区。提供优质护理。这在LaCite学院是可能的。
with the CIT. Visit CollageLacacac .C. D.M. A new initiative of the Consortium National of Formation in Health, supported by Santee Canada.
访问CollageLacite.com。这是国家健康培训联盟的一项新倡议，由加拿大卫生部支持。
There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Creveith and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum.
那些眼睛里空无一物。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。醒醒，恶魔。我是那个亲眼目睹Creveith和DePippo谋杀案的人。Anthony DePippo在被判处最高刑罚后，表现得毫无悔意，似乎并未受到影响。
I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chat. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now.
我说我没有罪。我会把这个秘密带进坟墓。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Bone Valley频道中的“魔鬼采石场”。快乐是必不可少的，也是难以捉摸的，但现在有一种令人兴奋的新方法可以开启您通往更快乐生活的旅程。Joy 101。这是一个由我，Hoda Kotby主持的新播客。如果您渴望获得灵感来最大化您的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的节目。打开您免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索Joy 101并立即收听。
Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbi is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier El Chichariot Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Here. Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast.
由CVS呈现的Joy 101与Hoda Kotbi。每个人都视我为足球运动员，但首先，我是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何处理问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。只是关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是Javier El Chichariot Hernandez，请在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“Learning to Be Here”。
June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped like 30 albums. We dropped like five right now. That's the rate we got to be going.
六月是黑人音乐月，在Drink Chams播客上，我们正在与文化界最热门的人物交谈，比如Sway Lee。你意识到你有多传奇吗？我很感激。我本想说，但我感觉，天哪，我还有很多事情要做。比如Prince，他发行了大约30张专辑。我们现在才发行了五张。这就是我们必须前进的速度。
Yep, that's a good attitude. No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversation. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. I have been really looking forward to this episode because today, not only do we have our first guest for our Netflix episodes, if you are watching over there, but we are talking about something a lot of us have experienced in very small ways, but very few people have experienced on a massive,
是的，那是一个很好的态度。无论在哪个时代，Drink Chams都会为您带来最大牌的人物和最直白的对话。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听来自Black Effect播客网络的Drink Chams。大家好。我是Jemma Spake，欢迎回到“心理学与你的20多岁”，这是一个我们探讨20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听另一集。我一直非常期待这一集，因为今天，我们不仅有Netflix剧集的第一位嘉宾（如果你在那边观看的话），而且我们正在谈论一个我们很多人在很小程度上经历过，但很少有人在巨大的、
kind of life-defining scale, which is growing up on the internet. Over the last two decades, as social media has become more omnipresent and posting our entire lives has become more normalized. I think a lot of us are having this weird experience whereby our identity, our mistakes, our awkward years, our best years, our relationships are all documented, not just for us, but for other people. On a small scale, that might mean like embarrassing Facebook memories. For others, it means like millions of people getting to see you as you are still trying to figure out your life, expecting you to be the same, expecting you to grow in a certain way. And today's guest is somebody who has lived through all of that.
某种定义人生的规模上经历过的事情，那就是在互联网上成长。在过去的二十年里，随着社交媒体变得无处不在，发布我们整个生活变得越来越常态化。我认为我们很多人都有这种奇怪的经历，即我们的身份、我们的错误、我们尴尬的岁月、我们最好的岁月、我们的人际关系都被记录了下来，不仅是为了我们自己，也是为了其他人。在小范围内，这可能意味着令人尴尬的Facebook回忆。对其他人来说，这意味着数以百万计的人看着你，而你还在试图弄清楚你的生活，期望你保持不变，期望你以某种方式成长。而今天的嘉宾就是经历过这一切的人。
And more, she is one of the original YouTube creators or I would say YouTube It Girls of our generation. And she built a platform where I think at a time where nobody really understood what the internet could really become. And now as she enters her 30s, she is here to talk to us about that experience and how it has shaped her and her relationship to creating now. Arden Rose, welcome to the psychology of your 20s. Hi. Thank you so much for having. me. Oh, I'm so excited. I'm so excited to be here. I feel like you gave me a really nice setup. Really? Did you like my intro? I really did. Yeah, because I think it gave a good, I don't know, like a grounding of how I felt for a really long time, but I never put it into words.
不仅如此，她是最初的YouTube创作者之一，或者我会说是我们这一代的YouTube“It Girl”。她建立了一个平台，我认为在那个时候，没有人真正理解互联网最终会变成什么样。现在，当她进入30岁时，她来到这里与我们谈论那种经历，以及它如何塑造了她以及她现在与创作的关系。Arden Rose，欢迎来到“心理学与你的20多岁”。嗨。非常感谢邀请我。哦，我太兴奋了。我很高兴能来到这里。我觉得你给了我一个非常好的开场白。真的吗？你喜欢我的介绍吗？我真的很喜欢。是的，因为我认为它给了我一个很好的，我不知道，就像对我长期以来的感受的一种定位，但我从未用语言表达出来。
Oh my God, that's what we always endeavor to do. We're going to talk about it so much, but you know what we were talking about on the elevator app is that you used to have a podcast? Yeah, I did. I did. It was called Crash on my couch, and it was really cute. It was me and my husband. been doing it together before we were married. And we would just talk about, like, random stuff. Like, he was really into the idea of getting to eventually go on a treasure hunt, which I think all straight cismen have some kind of fantasy for. And so we used to go on these, like, deep dives about, like, hidden treasures that we might be able to find and stuff like that. And then my segments were all about, like, animals that were extraordinary in the news.
天哪，这就是我们一直努力做到的。我们会谈论很多，但你知道我们在电梯应用程序上谈论的是什么吗？你以前有一个播客？是的，我有。我有。它叫“Crash on my couch”，真的很可爱。是我和我丈夫在我们结婚前一起做的。我们只是谈论一些随机的事情。比如，他真的很喜欢最终去寻宝的想法，我认为所有直男都有某种幻想。所以我们过去常常深入研究我们可能找到的隐藏宝藏之类的东西。然后我的部分都是关于新闻中非凡的动物。
Very, very diverse, very interesting topics that we were tackling. Important stuff. Honestly, wait, this gives me a business idea. Oh, yeah? There is money on the table for people to do themed birthday parties for grown men where they set up treasure hunts for them. 100%. 100%. It's kind of the same thing as like an escape room in a lot of ways.
非常非常多样化，非常有趣的话题，我们正在处理。重要的事情。老实说，等等，这给了我一个商业点子。哦，是吗？对于那些为成年男性举办主题生日派对的人来说，这里有钱可赚，他们为他们设置寻宝游戏。百分之百。百分之百。这在很多方面和密室逃脱是一样的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. You think about it that way. They yearn for it. They yearn, they yearn to be trapped somewhere and to have to steal a golden eye roll. I think that's like the Indiana Jones of it all. Yeah. Yeah. Would you ever do another podcast?
是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。你那样想。他们渴望它。他们渴望，他们渴望被困在某个地方，不得不去偷一个金色的眼球。我认为这就是印第安纳·琼斯的那种感觉。是啊。是啊。你还会再做播客吗？
I would. I just, I think I need a partner like you. I need like a cool gal pal to chat with. Galpal podcasts are really, really what it is. You know what I've realized is that I didn't even let you introduce yourself. So for people who may not know who you are, can you briefly introduce yourself? Tell us about your work. Tell us about yourself.
我会的。我只是，我觉得我需要一个像你这样的搭档。我需要一个酷酷的闺蜜来聊天。闺蜜播客真的是现在的潮流。你知道我意识到什么了吗？我甚至没有让你自我介绍。所以对于那些可能不知道你是谁的人，你能简单地介绍一下自己吗？告诉我们你的工作。告诉我们关于你自己的事情。
And yeah, how do you think most people know you? Yeah. Okay. Well, my name's Arden Rose. So that is my name. My actual name is Arden Rose Bricks. But I've always used my middle name just because like every basic white girl I have the middle name, Rose. And also my first name was so weird, but I feel like I needed, like, kind of a normal
还有，你认为大多数人是怎么认识你的？是的。好的。嗯，我的名字是Arden Rose。所以这就是我的名字。我真正的名字是Arden Rose Bricks。但我一直用我的中间名，因为就像每个普通的白人女孩一样，我有中间名Rose。而且我的名字太奇怪了，但我感觉我需要一个正常的
second name to back it up. Where is your first name from? You know what? It's so funny. My mom came up with it. She used to live in Texas while she was pregnant with me. And she had a neighbor who used to make her baked goods, who was like quite an older lady. And I think her name was Arden, or her second name was Arden or her last name was Arden. And I'm assuming, because I've looked it up a few times that it has something to do with French spelling of Arden, which is like A-R-D-E-N-N-E-S. But my name is A-R-D-E-N. Like, Garden Without the G is what I tell every barista that ever has to write my name down. That is a great mnemonic device.
第二个名字来支撑它。你的名字是从哪里来的？你知道吗？太搞笑了。我妈妈想出来的。她怀孕时住在德克萨斯州。她有一个邻居，过去常给她做烘焙食品，是一位相当年长的女士。我想她的名字是Arden，或者她的第二个名字是Arden，或者她的姓是Arden。我假设，因为我查过几次，它与Arden的法语拼写有关，就像A-R-D-E-N-N-E-S。但我的名字是A-R-D-E-N。就像“没有G的Garden”，这是我告诉每一个必须写下我名字的咖啡师的话。那是一个很棒的助记符。
Yeah, because I've never heard the name Arden before. It's a weird one, man. Would you... If you had kids and not to like, we were literally talking about this before, would you give them a unique name? I totally would. I think about it all the time because I think it's like, it's... I think it's like really lame that men are allowed to carry their names down and like women don't have like as much of an okay to do it because Arden is such a cool name. Like I remember being a kid and being like, I've got a cool name. You know what I mean? I wasn't bullied for my name. Maybe I would hate it if I was bullied for my name. But I like I really want it to be like my kid's name now. Make the rules. Maybe I will. You should totally do it. I'll do a Laura like Gilmore thing. Well, I think that we must. Yes. I thought this post the other day that was like middle names used to be the way that women could pass down their names to their
是的，因为我以前从未听说过Arden这个名字。这是一个奇怪的名字，伙计。你会……如果你有孩子，不是说我们刚才在谈论这个，你会给他们起一个独特的名字吗？我绝对会。我一直都在想，因为我觉得这就像，这……我觉得男人被允许传承他们的名字，而女性没有那么多机会这样做，这真的很烂，因为Arden是一个很酷的名字。就像我记得小时候，心想，我有一个很酷的名字。你知道我的意思吗？我没有因为我的名字而被欺负。也许如果我因为名字被欺负，我会讨厌它。但我真的很想现在把它作为我孩子的名字。制定规则。也许我会的。你绝对应该这样做。我会做一个像《吉尔莫女孩》里Laura那样的事情。嗯，我认为我们必须这样做。是的，我前几天看到这个帖子，说中间名曾经是女性传承她们名字的方式，
to not be erased from the history of their children. And I was like, so I think it's going to be the new trend. Yeah, I think that's a good idea. I think Arden's a good middle name too. Yeah, beautiful middle name. Yeah. I completely interrupted you as you were talking about your beginning. No, I appreciate it.
为了不被她们孩子的历史所抹去。然后我想，所以我认为这将是新的趋势。是的，我认为这是一个好主意。我认为Arden也是一个很好的中间名。是的，美丽的中间名。是的。你谈论你的开始时，我完全打断了你。不，我很感激。
No, I so appreciate it. Well, I think it's so funny. I think I have like different iterations of people who have watched me. Like there are some people who have literally watched me since I was like 14 years old in my like childhood bedroom in Little Rock, Arkansas. And to those, shouts out, y'all have. are the real ones out there. But yeah, that's a very different crowd than the people who probably found me in, like,
不，我非常感激。嗯，我觉得这太搞笑了。我觉得我有不同阶段的观众。有些人从我14岁起就一直在看我，在阿肯色州小石城的童年卧室里。对于那些人，大声喊出来，你们是真正的粉丝。但是，是的，那和那些可能在……中找到我的人群非常不同。
their college years when I had, like, just moved to L.A. and I was, like, living with all of these girls. We had kind of, like, a not a content house necessarily, because that was not a thing at the time. But it was, like, four girls who were all YouTubers living together, but doing, like, kind of separate things. And that was an era of time that people might know me. And then, like, as I grew up, then I started traveling more and met, my husband and eventually now have immigrated to the UK. What was it like in that content house,
他们的大学时代，当时我刚搬到洛杉矶，和所有这些女孩住在一起。我们当时有一种，不一定是内容屋，因为那时还没有那种东西。但那是四个都是YouTuber的女孩住在一起，但做着各自不同的事情。那是人们可能认识我的一个时代。然后，随着我长大，我开始更多地旅行，遇到了我的丈夫，最终现在移民到了英国。那个内容屋是什么样的，
like this YouTube house that you're in? You said it wasn't a content house. It feels like content house has a derogatory, like, because I just think of like the hype house for like team 10, which now feels like the ancient texts. Like, you know what I mean? Even though that was like, what, 10 years ago? It feels like it was like 20 years ago. But it was really cool. It was like kind of a funny thing because it's playing off a theme of like growing up on the internet, but I experienced a lot of like what people probably would have had in university or in college, like that same socialization with people who are in the same like peer group as you. But I was having it visibly online with other girls that were also having it visibly online while we were all
就像你所在的那个YouTube房子？你说它不是内容屋。感觉“内容屋”有一个贬义，因为我只是想到像Team 10的Hype House，现在感觉就像古代文献。就像，你知道我的意思吗？即使那是，什么，10年前？感觉就像20年前一样。但它真的很酷。这就像是一种有趣的事情，因为它是在玩弄在互联网上成长的这个主题，但我经历了很多人们在大学里可能经历的事情，比如与你同龄的人进行同样的社交。但我是在网上明显地和其他女孩一起经历的，她们也在网上明显地经历着，同时我们都在
maintaining friendships together. So I think that was complicated because when you're 18 and 19, like that's a complicated relationships anyways oh my goodness um and so but i really enjoyed it it was like yeah and then also this is so random but like the whole reason that my husband and i got together was because rebecca black of friday thing yeah came over to our house and like we had had a night out the night before and she stayed over and the next morning we were all having breakfast together and i was like who's this random british guy that keeps sliding into my dms like who is this little did I know that I had already met him and I completely forgotten I had met him. But she like vouched for him and was like, oh no, he's really cool.
保持着友谊。所以我认为这很复杂，因为当你18岁和19岁时，那无论如何都是复杂的关系，天哪，嗯，所以，但我真的很喜欢它，就像，是的，还有这个太随机了，但我丈夫和我在一起的全部原因是因为Rebecca Black的那个“Friday”的事情，是的，她来到我们家，我们前一天晚上出去玩了，她留宿了，第二天早上我们都在一起吃早餐，我心想，这个一直滑进我私信的随机英国人是谁？他是谁？我一点都不知道我已经见过他了，而且我完全忘记了我见过他。但她为他担保，说，哦不，他真的很酷。
And you two would totally hit it off. Like you guys should go on a date together. No way. Yeah. So it's kind of butterfly effect. Like if I hadn't, you know, lived with those girls, I probably would have never. I wouldn't be sat here probably. I know.
你们两个绝对会合得来。你们应该去约会。不会吧。是的。所以这有点像蝴蝶效应。如果我没有（你知道）和那些女孩住在一起，我可能永远不会。我可能不会坐在这里。我知道。
Yeah. Take me back to like your first YouTube video. And before, because I have a lot of questions about this era of your life. But when did you post like your first video online? Yeah. You know what? It's so funny. It's like, it's really funny to think about how the history of YouTubers, like the history of the internet, like I was kind of not there for the creation of it, but I was there watching people go from doing like makeup tutorials online to being
是的。带我回到你第一个YouTube视频的时候。在那之前，因为我对你生命中的这个时代有很多疑问。但是你什么时候在网上发布了你的第一个视频？是的。你知道吗？太搞笑了。想到YouTuber的历史，就像互联网的历史，我有点没有参与它的创造，但我一直在那里看着人们从在网上做化妆教程到成为
like personalities online and like how that transformed and like why that shifted and changed. And I think in my case, it happened really organically because I was admiring all these like beauty gurus, you know, like the OG beauty gurus at the time, like Juicy Star 07 and all the, you know, Blair Fowler and L. Fowler and like, you know, all these people and Gigi gorgeous. Gigi Gorgeous. I used to watch her religiously. Girl, like so many different people. Bub's Beauty, I don't know if you remember her. She was, she's like an, I think she was Irish, but she was like an amazing Michelle Hawn. Oh my God. Yeah, I do. And she had read, is this what I'm thinking of Bugs Beauty?
网上的个性人物，以及它是如何转变的，以及为什么它发生了转移和改变。我认为在我的情况下，它发生得非常自然，因为我当时很崇拜所有这些美妆博主，你知道，比如当时的OG美妆博主，比如Juicy Star 07，还有所有那些，你知道，Blair Fowler和L. Fowler，还有，你知道，所有这些人，还有Gigi Gorgeous。Gigi Gorgeous。我过去常虔诚地看她的视频。天哪，就像这么多不同的人。Bub's Beauty，我不知道你是否还记得她。她，她是，我想她是爱尔兰人，但她就像一个了不起的Michelle Hawn。天哪。是的，我记得。她读过，这是我在想的Bugs Beauty吗？
Bugs Beauty, I think, is different than Bubs Beauty. Oh, okay. But she had really cute dog. I know. It's just so fun. Everyone had such cute usernames. I wish we stuck to usernames. But, you know, it was kind of the era still of like the Stranger Danger era, which is so
Bugs Beauty，我想，和Bubs Beauty不同。哦，好的。但她有一只非常可爱的狗。我知道。这太有趣了。每个人都有这么可爱的用户名。我希望我们坚持使用用户名。但是，你知道，那仍然是“陌生人危险”时代的时代，这太
funny because now everyone posts everything always. But I was just watching these people and really loving it. And then I had a friend named Kennedy who went to my school when I was younger and then moved to Texas for, I think, for her dad's job. And when she moved, we would watch YouTube videos together, like in middle school. And so I started sending her, like, we would make kind of like fake beauty guru videos like to each other, like getting ready in the morning. And right? And so we would send it back and forth. But then it became a bit of this thing where like we both started getting followers from like people watching us get ready for each other. And so.
搞笑了，因为现在每个人总是发布所有东西。但我只是在看这些人，真的很喜欢它。然后我有一个叫Kennedy的朋友，我年轻时和她上同一所学校，后来因为她爸爸的工作搬到了德克萨斯州。当她搬走时，我们会在初中时一起看YouTube视频。所以我开始给她发，我们过去常制作那种假的美容博主视频给对方，比如早上准备好。对吧？所以我们来回发送。但后来它变成了一点点，我们俩都开始从看我们为对方准备的人那里获得粉丝。所以。
became this thing where like that's kind of where it started and I lost all those videos which I'm really sad about like I think I privateed all of them when I was probably like 18 because I just thought I'm so young in these videos even at 18 I was like I'm too young to be like have these videos on the internet yeah um which is also really funny because even at that that time when I was posting as like a 14 year old girl I and I mean this sincerely never had a creepy comment not once I was completely I don't know what I don't know what was looking out for me really but I I was completely sheltered from like purves. Were your parents worried about that?
变成了那种开始的地方，我丢失了所有那些视频，我对此感到非常难过，我想我可能在18岁左右把它们都设为私密了，因为我只是觉得我在这些视频里太年轻了，即使在18岁时，我也觉得我太年轻了，不能把这些视频放在互联网上，是的，嗯，这也真的很搞笑，因为即使在那个时候，当我作为一个14岁的女孩发布视频时，我，我是真诚的，从来没有收到过令人毛骨悚然的评论，一次都没有，我完全，我不知道，我不知道是什么在照顾我，真的，但我完全被保护起来，免受那些变态的侵害。你的父母担心吗？
Did they ask you? Well, they didn't exactly know about it initially. I, the only reason I told my parents about it when I was, I think I was 16 years old when I finally told them. So I'd been like two years of very intermittent posting. Like I would post like a video and I would post like four videos a week and then I wouldn't post for like two months. Yeah. You know, like just team stuff. And then I, Google AdSense became a thing.
他们问过你吗？嗯，他们最初并不完全知道。我，我告诉父母这件事的唯一原因是在我，我想我16岁时终于告诉了他们。所以我已经断断续续地发布了两年。就像我会发布一个视频，然后我一周会发布四个视频，然后我会有两个月不发布。是的。你知道，就像团队的事情。然后我，Google AdSense变成了一件事。
And you needed to have a bank account and you needed to have a bank account and you needed to have your parents' permission if you were going to sign up. I was 16 years old and I was like, I think I can make money doing this. Like that was the first like inkling that anything. And I think I probably had like 20,000 followers on YouTube at the time. Granted, also the other thing about YouTube at that time was that it was such a small ecosystem that there weren't that many people to watch that were making content like that. So like it's so ubiquitous now. Everyone, everyone has access to it and everyone feels. Everybody's thought about it. Yeah, totally. I have to admit like everybody has thought about, what if I made YouTube videos? What if I post a TikToks?
你需要有一个银行账户，你需要有一个银行账户，如果你要注册，你需要有父母的许可。我当时16岁，我想，我想我可以通过做这个赚钱。就像那是第一次暗示任何事情。我想我当时在YouTube上可能有20,000名粉丝。当然，关于那个时候的YouTube，另一件事是它是一个如此小的生态系统，没有那么多人看那些制作那种内容的人。所以，它现在太无处不在了。每个人，每个人都有权访问它，每个人都感觉。每个人都想过它。是的，完全。我必须承认，每个人都想过，如果我制作YouTube视频会怎样？如果我发布TikTok会怎样？
Absolutely. So it was, but it was like at the time for me, it was like a thing like, you can make money doing that. You know what I mean? Like, oh, okay, well, that's interesting. So I remember I told them when I was 16 and they were like, well, are you being safe? Like not knowing what question to really ask me for that. Like, are you like an amorphous, are you being safe? And I'm like, yes, I think. Like, I'm 16. Like, I don't know. But I was also, I'm one of four kids. So I think they were. just like happy that I wasn't, you know, joining some kind of cult. Yeah, yeah, yeah, doing something else nefarious. It's so interesting that you're like, I never got a creepy comment, but your first
绝对。所以，但在当时对我来说，这就像一件事，你可以通过做那个赚钱。你知道我的意思吗？哦，好的，好吧，那很有趣。所以我记得我在16岁时告诉了他们，他们说，你安全吗？就像不知道该问我什么问题。就像，你是一个无定形的，你安全吗？我说，是的，我想。就像，我16岁。就像，我不知道。但我也是，我是四个孩子中的一个。所以我认为他们只是很高兴我没有，你知道，加入某种邪教。是的，是的，是的，做其他邪恶的事情。你从来没有收到过令人毛骨悚然的评论，这太有趣了，但你的第一个
video you posted when you were 14, yeah. And what, wait, what was that video? Was it like I could get ready with me? Yeah, I think it was a get ready with me. It also could have been like a review of something. You know what it might have been? It might have been so, like, silly, like so lame now to think about. But I think at the time, you know, Mac Cosmetics was like huge. And I remember there was this significant. Right? And there was this brush called the Mac 217 brush that was like the blending brush. Everyone was like obsessed with.
视频是你14岁时发布的，是的。等等，那个视频是什么？是像“和我一起准备”吗？是的，我想是“和我一起准备”。它也可能是某样东西的评论。你知道它可能是什么吗？它可能太，就像，愚蠢，就像现在想起来太烂了。但我认为在当时，你知道，Mac Cosmetics就像巨大的。我记得有这个重要的。对吧？有一个叫Mac 217刷子的刷子，那是混合刷。每个人都着迷。
I can see it in my mind's eye to this day. What color was it black? It was, well, all the black like Mac handles. And then it had white like really soft bristles. I remember this. I want this brush now. But maybe they've changed it. I don't know.
直到今天，我还能在脑海中看到它。它是什么颜色的？黑色？它是，嗯，所有黑色的Mac手柄。然后它有白色的，非常柔软的刷毛。我记得这个。我现在想要这个刷子。但也许他们改变了它。我不知道。
But I remember I went to Mac and I bought that and I bought, I think a single eye shadow. and I came home and I did a haul with my two items. Oh, my goodness. My heart. I probably thought I was being so cool because Michelle Fawn used that brush. So I was like, I got it. Well, this is what I was going to ask you about. It was like back then, which you've kind of already answered.
但我记得我去了Mac，我买了那个，我买了，我想是一个单色眼影。然后我回家了，我用我的两件商品做了一个开箱。天哪。我的心。我可能以为我很酷，因为Michelle Fawn用了那个刷子。所以我心想，我得到了它。好吧，这就是我要问你的。就像那时，你已经回答了。
And what is it like to watch those videos back now, knowing what the internet is these days? because back then it was such low production value. Yeah. And it was really organic. And now it's this, it's mega. Like literally people now realize like being online can make you a millionaire, could make you a billionaire in some situations. Maybe we're not at that level yet.
现在回看那些视频是什么感觉，知道互联网现在是什么样子？因为那时生产价值太低了。是的。而且它真的很自然。而现在它是这个，它是巨大的。就像字面意思，人们现在意识到，在网上可以让你成为百万富翁，在某些情况下可以让你成为亿万富翁。也许我们还没有达到那个水平。
But pretty close. Like what was it before that kind of, what was it like before that took over? Yeah. I don't, it's interesting because it's like, you're so right. People just didn't really have like the means to figure out that it was such a thing until it was and then everyone who could possibly exploit it, kind of like figured out how to work algorithms and stuff.
但很接近。在那之前是什么样的，在那之前是什么样的？是的。我不，这很有趣，因为它就像，你说得太对了。人们只是没有办法弄清楚它是一件大事，直到它是，然后每个可能利用它的人，有点像弄清楚了如何操作算法之类的东西。
I think that was like a really interesting phase of YouTube. But I think before that point, there was this real kind of like ooey-goey-goor of people on YouTube that were like kind of, not anti-social people, because I think that has like a negative connotation, but people that maybe felt more comfortable being creative in their bedrooms on the internet,
我认为那是YouTube的一个非常有趣的阶段。但我认为在那之前，YouTube上有一种真正的那种……人们在YouTube上，就像那种，不是反社会的人，因为我认为那有负面含义，但那些可能觉得在互联网上的卧室里创作更舒服的人，
which is like a very different thing than wanting to make money on the internet. Right? Like that's like those are two different types of people. Oh yeah. And sometimes that have been diagram exists. But for me, it was like I didn't feel like I had a lot of friends at school. My friend Kennedy had just moved.
这就像一件非常不同的事情，而不是想在互联网上赚钱。对吧？就像那是两种不同类型的人。哦，是的。有时那个维恩图存在。但对我来说，就像我觉得我在学校里没有很多朋友。我的朋友Kennedy刚搬走。
You know, I was like joining cheer and I was like very awkward. And I was just like I had a really bad haircut at the time. And I think all of that to be said, I think like I was looking to express myself to someone or something like just like gab out loud. I was kind of screaming into the void Yeah But by just like showing Mac eye shadows You know Yeah
你知道，我加入了啦啦队，我非常尴尬。我只是，我当时剪了一个非常糟糕的发型。我认为所有这些都要说，我认为我是在寻求向某人或某事表达自己，或者只是大声说出来。我有点在对着虚空尖叫，是的，但只是通过展示Mac眼影，你知道，是的。
Yeah yeah love me Except me Help me help me figure out How to be like a young woman Yeah So yeah That was sort of like The genesis of it
是的，是的，爱我，接受我，帮帮我，帮帮我弄清楚如何成为一个年轻女性，是的，所以，是的，那有点像是它的起源。
And then also like I There were limitations as far as like Set up Like I had to wait for my dad To come home Because his crappy laptop
然后还有，我，在设置方面有限制，就像我必须等我爸爸回家，因为他那台烂笔记本电脑
Had a webcam in it You filmed on the On the MacBook? It wasn't even a MacBook It was like an HP It was so buggy it was so bad. I remember like there were months where I couldn't record anything because he would get so many viruses on his laptop that he would have to like go get it wipes. Like I remember when that was a thing. Yes. MacAfee, babe. Oh yeah, big time. So yeah, there was like, yeah, just moments where like stuff like that would happen. It was just kind of like an organic break. Yeah. And then, but I remember there were times like that where I would go on my comment section and, you know, there'd be like five or five or six comments on a video. And one of them would be like, where's she been all this time? And it's like, it's. It's. It's.
里面有一个摄像头。你是在MacBook上拍摄的吗？那甚至不是MacBook，它就像一台HP，它太不稳定了，太糟糕了。我记得有几个月我无法录制任何东西，因为他的笔记本电脑会感染很多病毒，他不得不去把它擦除。我记得那是怎么回事。是的，McAfee，宝贝。哦，是的，大时间。所以，是的，有那种，是的，只是那种事情会发生的时刻。这就像是一种自然的休息。是的。然后，但我记得有几次，我会去我的评论区，你知道，视频上有五六条评论。其中一条会说，她这段时间去哪了？这很有趣，
funny to think that that was the reason I wasn't there. Yeah. I mean, you were like, I feel seen. Like, people miss me. Don't worry, girls. I'm coming back. All three of you watching, I'm coming back. Yeah. Sorry, guys, I've been on a little break. I just want to be completely transparent about what's been going on. Yes. Let's address it. Lots of stuff happening in my personal life. Lots of viruses on my dad's laptop. Yeah. What was the first video of yours that went like viral? It was and was like virality even a thing back then. Yeah, it definitely was. I think virality had a had a different connotation. Like, I'll use Rebecca as an example.
想到这就是我不在那里的原因。是的。我的意思是，你就像，我觉得被看见了。就像，人们想念我。别担心，女孩们。我会回来的。所有三个看视频的人，我会回来的。是的，抱歉，伙计们，我休息了一会儿。我只是想完全透明地说明发生了什么。是的。让我们解决它。我的个人生活发生了很多事情。我爸爸的笔记本电脑上有很多病毒。是的。你第一个走红的视频是什么？那时走红是一回事吗？是的，绝对是。我认为走红在当时有不同的含义。就像，我会用Rebecca作为一个例子。
Like Friday had a very different virality than what viral is today. Like, viral today is something popular for a week. Yeah. Like, viral back then was popular for years. Yeah. Like, talked about for years. Yeah. Like, where have they been kind of vibes?
就像“Friday”有与今天走红完全不同的走红。就像，今天的走红是流行一周的东西。是的。就像，那时的走红是流行多年。是的。就像，被谈论多年。是的。就像，那种“他们去哪了”的氛围。
You know, like, when you think about the chocolate rain guy, Tezonde, or Rebecca for Friday, or, like, all these people, like, they still have these, like, statements next to them like, you know, capital chocolate rain guy. Yeah. Because they were like, you know, integral parts of the internet. Whereas now it's like nothing can really. And nobody can trace it back to who started it. No, exactly. Yeah. And it's, yeah. And I don't know. We can't just anything nowadays. So it's just like hard for it for anyone to like be 100% on anything. Yeah, we live in a really weird time. But at the time, I think I did a video. This is so lame. but so the bad haircut happened and then I made a video
你知道，就像，当你想到巧克力雨那个家伙，Tezonde，或者Rebecca的“Friday”，或者，像，所有这些人，就像，他们仍然有这些，就像，他们旁边的陈述，就像，你知道，大写的巧克力雨家伙。是的。因为他们就像，你知道，互联网不可或缺的一部分。而现在就像没有什么能真正。而且没有人能追溯到是谁开始的。不，完全正确。是的。而且，是的。而且我不知道。我们现在什么都不能。所以这就像很难让任何人对任何事情百分之百确定。是的，我们生活在一个非常奇怪的时代。但在当时，我想我做了一个视频。这太烂了，
where I had researched a bunch of stuff as a probably 15 year old okay 16 year old maybe of ways that I could grow my hair back so wait what was the haircut we need to know the haircut first it was just a bob it was a bob like it was just a bob
但所以糟糕的发型发生了，然后我做了一个视频，
but it wasn't like a funky little bob it was like a no it wasn't a chic it wasn't a chic it wasn't French Claire but it was fine it wasn't atrocious like I think I was just like insecure And I was a, you know, a Southern girl who had...
我研究了一堆东西，作为一个可能15岁，好的，16岁，也许，我可以让头发长回来的方法，所以等等，发型是什么？我们需要先知道发型。它只是一个波波头，它只是一个波波头，
15, 16. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. So I had made this video and it went really, really viral. Like, I think it had like millions of views. Wow. Which is so funny because it was obviously just people like, before I knew what SEO was. Oh, yeah.
但它不是一个时髦的小波波头，它就像一个，不，它不是一个别致的，它不是一个别致的，它不是法国克莱尔，但它很好，它并不残忍，就像我想我只是，就像不安全，而且我是一个，你知道，南方女孩，有……
It's like someone just searching, I don't want to grow my hair back. And they're getting some dumb ass 16 year old and Little Rock Arkansas telling them how to grow that, like, I know anything. What was your advice? Was it like... I don't even remember. It was bad. You could barely hear it. The audio is so bad.
15，16。是的，完全。完全。所以我做了这个视频，它真的，真的走红了。就像，我想它有数百万的观看次数。哇。这太搞笑了，因为它显然只是人们，在我知道SEO是什么之前。哦，是的。
And again, I'm recording it on like either, do you remember those flip cameras? Yes. It was either one of those which sounded like you were, it sounded and looked like you were in the ocean. Or it was my dad's MacBook, which also looked like it was in the ocean. So. But being in the ocean is good for the hair. You know it. So true.
就像有人只是搜索，我不想让我的头发长回来。他们得到了一些愚蠢的16岁小孩在阿肯色州小石城告诉他们如何长那个，就像，我知道任何事情。你的建议是什么？是像……我甚至不记得了。它很糟糕。你几乎听不到。音频太糟糕了。
Wait a second. It's all coming together. That is so funny. This brings me to, I think the real big question of this episode, which is like, what's been the hardest part of growing up online? Like you've spent half of your last. on the internet. Do you feel like as you've entered your 30s, like people who know you from back then have like expectations for you?
而且，我是在像，你还记得那些翻盖摄像机吗？是的。它要么是其中之一，听起来像你，听起来和看起来像你在海洋里。或者它是我的爸爸的MacBook，它看起来也像在海洋里。所以。但在海洋里对头发有好处。你知道的。这太真实了。
Yeah. I think I have like a really interesting audience. Like I said, I've like picked up these like little core cool girl groups all say like throughout time and space. But for the most part, I have always had like a really intelligent, really emotionally mature and very kind audience. Like I've always had really, really sweet people follow me. I've never felt bullied by my audience.
等一下。一切都联系在一起了。这太搞笑了。这让我想到，我认为这一集真正的大问题，那就是，在网上成长的最困难的部分是什么？就像你度过了你最后的一半。在互联网上。你觉得当你进入30岁时，那些从那时起就认识你的人对你有期望吗？
And I've never felt like put on the back foot. And I think part of that is because I've never been someone who has like that serious viral fame that usually comes with some kind of outrage or, you know, like. I don't know. Like I always just think about how like as women, if you get to a certain point of virality, there will always be like a guillotine waiting for you. You know what I mean? Like Chapel Rhone is a great example right now. Like don't even get me. started on that because I could go on for so long about that. But, but, but so I've had kind of like
是的。我想我有一个非常有趣的观众。就像我说的，我一直在时间和空间中挑选这些小核心酷女孩群体。但在大多数情况下，我一直有一个非常聪明、非常情绪成熟且非常善良的观众。就像我一直有非常，非常甜美的人关注我。我从来没有觉得被我的观众欺负过。
this weird privilege where because I've been a bit of a middling creator in the sense that like, I've, you know, I still have like millions of followers, but people have tens of millions of followers now. People have like hundreds of millions of followers now. Um, I've always been able to maintain this like cool, smart, sweet group of people all the way through. Yeah. And that's been like such a blessing. Yeah. I honestly relate to the. that a lot. I have this full theory that it's like an elevator. It's a Taylor Swift lyric. Okay. It's like an elevator that rises. Yeah. Elevator that rises too fast, like never lasts. And I genuinely do believe it where it's like a lot of people will get online and be like,
而且我从来没有觉得被置于后脚。我认为部分原因是，因为我从来不是那种拥有那种通常伴随着某种愤怒的严重病毒式名声的人，或者，你知道，像。我不知道。就像我总是想到，作为女性，如果你达到了一定的走红程度，总会有一个断头台在等着你。你知道我的意思吗？就像Chapel Rhone现在就是一个很好的例子。就像甚至不要让我。开始谈论那个，因为我可以谈论那个很久。但是，但是，但是，所以我有一种
I want to be famous and I want this and I want that. And it's like, be careful what you wish for. Like the slow burn of like really caring and about what you're doing is going to take you so much further. And it's really interesting, something you said before of like you started YouTube because, like, it sounds like you just really wanted to make videos because you just liked it. And, you know, you were waiting for your dad to get home and you were trying to communicate with your long-distance friend and you were just like enjoying it as a craft. And I think that's something that people these days don't have. Yeah. People always like, how do you start a podcast?
这种奇怪的特权，因为我是一个有点平庸的创作者，在这个意义上，就像，我，你知道，我仍然有数百万的粉丝，但人们现在有数千万的粉丝。人们现在有数亿的粉丝。嗯，我一直能够自始至终保持这个酷、聪明、甜美的群体。是的。那真是一种祝福。是的。我老实说，与那个有很多共鸣。我有一个完整的理论，它就像一个电梯。这是一个泰勒·斯威夫特的歌词。好的。它就像一个上升的电梯。是的。上升太快的电梯，从来不会持久。我真的相信它，就像很多人会上网，然后说，
Like, how did you make money off your podcast up about? And it's like, you don't start at wanting to make money. Yeah. Like, that's literally, you've already lost. Like the moment you're like, I want to do this so that I can be. famous. Yeah. If you're like one percent of people who have that intention, maybe it happens, but it like drops off so quickly. It's like this whole crazy, crazy thing. You don't have the inner well to keep up the energy to keep doing stuff. If that's the main goal, then once you get
我想出名，我想要这个，我想要那个。然后就像，小心你所希望的。就像那种真正关心你正在做的事情的缓慢燃烧会带你走得更远。而且这真的很有趣，你之前说的，你开始YouTube是因为，听起来你只是真的很想制作视频，因为你只是喜欢它。而且，你知道，你在等你的爸爸回家，你在试图与你的远距离朋友交流，你只是在享受它作为一种手艺。我认为这是人们现在没有的东西。是的。人们总是问，你怎么开始播客？
famous or once you get enough money, then like where's the spark to continue it? Yeah, it's nowhere. Or once you get your first, like have you ever had any controversy? Because I feel like once you get your first thing like that. Yeah. Then it knocks you off. Oh, yeah, yeah. Yeah. I know. I haven't really ever had a big controversy. I like, I stream video games. So I do like, I play cozy games online. Really? Yeah. Oh, my God. I didn't know that. Oh, yeah. On the Twitch. Yeah, yeah. And like, especially on, um, I used to play a lot of Animal Crossing. So like, Animal Crossing was my big game all through lockdown. Um, and during like the whole Black Lives Matter movement, I raised a bunch of money for the bail project. Like the most money I've ever raised for charity. And it was like such a big deal to
就像，你是怎么从你的播客中赚钱的？就像，你不是从想赚钱开始的。是的。就像，那字面意思，你已经输了。就像你想要做这个以便我可以出名的时候。是的。如果你是那百分之一有这种意图的人，也许它会发生，但它下降得太快了。这就像整个疯狂，疯狂的事情。你没有内在的井来保持能量继续做事情。如果那是主要目标，那么一旦你变得
me. But my family's very conservative. And so the only controversy is, Controversy as I have ever been in are with interpersonal relationships. I'm, I'll feel really good about something that I've done online and I'll be like, I'm really glad that I did that. And I feel really proud of like my audience to be able to do something like that. And then I get like pushback from my personal life. You have the reverse. Yes. Yeah. That is really interesting. Totally. So it's like a weird thing of sort of just being like, you know, having to kind of be my own best friend in that situation. Yeah. You know. Well, and it's often because people will find, you know, controversy online and to see. protection in your family. And it's like, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. It's, she's doing it different. You have the desire to help us. The College, LaCite, you offer the program
出名或者一旦你有足够的钱，那么，火花在哪里继续它？是的，它无处不在。或者一旦你有了你的第一次，就像你有没有过任何争议？因为我觉得一旦你有了你的第一次那种事情。是的。然后它把你击倒了。哦，是的，是的。是的。我知道。我从来没有过什么大的争议。我喜欢，我直播视频游戏。所以我做，我在网上玩舒适的游戏。真的吗？是的。哦，天哪。我不知道。哦，是的。在Twitch上。是的，是的。而且，特别是在，嗯，我过去常玩很多《动物森友会》。所以，就像《动物森友会》是我整个封锁期间的大游戏。嗯，在整个“黑人的命也是命”运动期间，我为保释项目筹集了一大笔钱。就像我为慈善机构筹集过的最多的钱。而且这对我来说是一件大事。
Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the health mental and deppandance. Construise a career enriching to service of the community
但我家非常保守。所以唯一的争议是，我曾经参与过的争议是人际关系。我，我会对我在线上做的事情感觉很好，我会说，我真的很高兴我做了那个。而且我为我的观众能够做那样的事情感到非常自豪。然后我从我的个人生活中得到了阻力。你有相反的情况。是的。是的。那真的很有趣。完全。所以这就像一种奇怪的事情，就像，你知道，在这种情况下不得不成为我最好的朋友。是的。你知道。嗯，而且这通常是因为人们会发现，你知道，网上的争议，并看到你家庭中的保护。然后就像，等等，等等，等等，等等。这是，她做得不同。您是否有意愿去帮助我们？LaCite学院，您提供课程
francophone of all the country. Don't know the soin of quality in French, it's possible with TheC. Visit Collage Lacitcite. comc. right now.
“依赖与心理健康”。获取必要的技能，以陪伴和支持那些面临心理健康和依赖困难的人们。建立一份充实的职业，服务于
An initiative of the Consortium National of Formation in Sanctus by Sancta Canada. In the
全国的法语社区。提供优质护理，这在LaCite学院是可能的。访问CollageLacite.com。
moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was
这是国家健康培训联盟的一项倡议，由加拿大卫生部支持。在
terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared
那一刻，感觉它好像永远在持续。我以为我活不下去了。我
the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the
很害怕。那些眼睛里空无一物。它们变成了黑色。这把我
biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder of a child 12-year-old as bad as it gets.
吓坏了。那是你的第一个谋杀案吗？是的，先生。恐怕这是你职业生涯中最大的案件？是的，先生。强奸并谋杀了一个12岁的孩子，这是最糟糕的事情。
I would think so. evil wake up i'm the woman saw the murder take place by crevette and de pippo anthony de pippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum i said i'm not guilty i'll take it to the grief listen to the devil's quarry on the i heart radio app apple podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts and to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content subscribe to love of for good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult.
我想也是。邪恶，醒醒，我是那个目睹了谋杀案的女人，克雷维特和德皮波，安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后毫无悔意，表现得泰然自若。我说我没有罪，我会把这件事带进坟墓。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《魔鬼的采石场》，想要收听无广告且包含独家内容的《魔鬼的采石场》，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅Love of for good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》的主持人。我们将一起与世界上最迷人的人进行有意义的对话，比如女演员奥利维亚·穆恩分享她是如何克服严峻健康挑战的。我经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过了乳腺癌，那更困难。
There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. And there's an ton of exciting because their new star is Javier Tichorito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born.
很多人了解产后抑郁症。但我对产后焦虑症毫无准备。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》。还有一件令人兴奋的事，因为他们的新星是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我视为一名足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我都在学习如何处理问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。
And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or
我仍然有很多问题。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何应对被取消？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是
Barza From every day and ordinary To the deep and extraordinary This isn't a normal podcast Everything here is spontaneous
巴萨？从日常平凡到深刻非凡，这不是一个普通的播客，这里的一切都是自发的。
Real and genuine This podcast is like a deep talk With your closest friends Where vulnerability comes out Conspiracy theories End up on the table
真实而纯粹。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行深度交谈，脆弱的一面展现出来，阴谋论最终被摆上台面。
And goals and lessons are shared In this life has a order Perfecto and all is just But hey I'm I'm going to
目标和经验被分享，在这个生活中，一切都有秩序，一切都是公正的。但嘿，我，我打算
I'm going to We are here to connect The Chicharito And Javier Chichorandoes And together with Ica Radio
我打算，我们在这里是为了建立联系，小豌豆和哈维尔·埃尔南德斯，以及与Ica Radio一起。
We're going to make the ordinary extraordinary. Stay close. It is a carac. Listen to learning to be human or I have radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Here's something that should
我们将让平凡变得非凡。保持关注。这是Carac。请在iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《学习做人》。这里有一些事情应该
not be as complicated as it is. Getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is. Getting a new one put up in its place. As long as there's a politics of race in America, there's going to be a politics of remembering the Civil War. To get to school,
不像现在这么复杂。移除种族主义雕像。这里有一些事情应该比现在容易得多。在原处放置一个新的。只要美国存在种族政治，就会存在关于纪念内战的政治。为了去学校，
I had to go down Robert Lee Boulevard. to the grocery store, I had to go down Jefferson Davis Parkway. If you're an historian and you leave out half of what the history is, you're not doing your job. I'm Akila Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 goes deep on both of those things. The fights, the politics, the people who won, and my personal campaign to add something to the Kentucky State House that's actually worth the wall space. We are more than our bodies. We contain essence.
我必须走罗伯特·李大道。去杂货店，我必须走杰斐逊·戴维斯大道。如果你是一位历史学家，却遗漏了一半的历史，那你就没有尽到你的职责。我是阿基拉·休斯，《反叛精神》第二季深入探讨了这两件事。斗争、政治、获胜的人，以及我个人为肯塔基州议会大厦增加一些真正值得占据墙面空间的东西的运动。我们不仅仅是我们的身体。我们包含本质。
We contain spirit. How do you represent that? They are just fueling a fire. That is really catching. You'll see what I mean. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Can we talk about something a bit more personal? Yeah.
我们包含精神。你如何代表这一点？他们只是在火上浇油。这真的很吸引人。你会明白我的意思。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《反叛精神》第二季。我们可以谈谈更私人的事情吗？好的。
Which was you obviously shared a lot of, you know, shared some of your experiences going through an eating disorder when you were online. Yeah. Do you think that like being online at a young age kind of contributed or do you think it was already there and just kind of followed you through those early years of the journey? Yeah. I think it's so funny like I mean nothing about eating disorders is funny but sometimes you got to you got a laugh but you cry but it's um I think for me I think I think disordered eating but a lot of like less understood but very culturally prevalent mental disorders are or like mental health problems are things that people broadly understand but don't but like the minutia of them are kind of like complicated and so for mine I have I had such like a combo where I felt really out of control when I was growing up and when I was a like a teenager, like felt very isolated from people in my school. And I also have Trichotillomania, which is like a hair pulling disorder. It's so bad right now. Like I have no eyelashes. But I used to
那就是你显然分享了很多，你知道，分享了一些你在网上时经历饮食失调的经历。是的。你认为在年轻时上网在某种程度上促成了这一点，还是你认为它本来就存在，只是在那些早年的旅程中一直伴随着你？是的。我觉得这太搞笑了，我是说饮食失调没什么好笑的，但有时你不得不笑，但你却哭了，但嗯，我想对我来说，我想我想饮食失调，但很多不太被理解但在文化上非常普遍的精神障碍或心理健康问题是人们广泛理解但却不了解细节的东西，它们有点复杂，所以对我来说，我有一种组合，我在成长过程中感到非常失控，当我还是个青少年时，在学校里感到与人非常隔绝。而且我还有拔毛癖，这是一种拔头发的障碍。现在太严重了。我连睫毛都没有了。但我过去
do that as well, but I started getting fake lashes. Yeah. And it helped me. Whoa, you have Trick. Well, I would just do my eyelashes. It was just like a nervous thing, but I never really identified as having it. I would just put my eyelashes out. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I would just put my eyelashes out. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I pull my ashes out too. It's funny. It's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, you know, because, like, you know, because, like, you understand, like, clinical psychology, but there's so many, like, layers and cross layers of what things could be, right? So when I was younger, I was like, I think I have OCD because I do this hair pulling thing. It's compulsive. And I also, my eating disorder was very wrapped up around, like, threes. Like, I would tell myself, I could only eat three things. So it was, it was like, interesting. I remember for a while it was, like, apples, triscuits, and cheese. And I can have as much as I wanted, but I just needed to eat those three things. And there was no reason, like, there was no religious reason, which threes are usually kind of a religious thing. And there was no, like, doom spiraling OCD if I don't do this, something bad's going to happen.
也这样做，但我开始戴假睫毛。是的。这对我很有帮助。哇，你有拔毛癖。嗯，我只是会拔我的睫毛。这就像是一种紧张的习惯，但我从未真正认定自己患有这种病。我只是会把睫毛拔掉。是的，是的，是的。我也会拔掉我的睫毛。这很有趣。这，这，这，你知道，因为，你知道，因为，你知道，因为，你理解临床心理学，但事物可能是什么有太多的层次和交叉层次，对吧？所以当我年轻的时候，我想，我想我有强迫症，因为我做了这个拔头发的事情。这是强迫性的。而且，我的饮食失调与“三”这个数字紧密相关。比如，我会告诉自己，我只能吃三样东西。所以这很有趣。我记得有一段时间是苹果、饼干和奶酪。我可以吃多少就吃多少，但我只需要吃那三样东西。而且没有理由，没有宗教原因，尽管三通常是一种宗教事物。也没有如果我不这样做就会发生坏事的强迫症式的末日螺旋。
But I just had this, like, feeling of control that was really important to me. So that's what my eating disorder kind of like started out as. And then as the internet developed, veganism got really big because of, Cowspiracy. And again, completely think that is so, like, valid. Yeah. But then there was this huge, like the way the pendulum swings, there was like that banana lady. What was her name?
但我只是有这种对我来说非常重要的控制感。所以这就是我的饮食失调开始的方式。然后随着互联网的发展，纯素食主义因为《奶牛阴谋》变得非常流行。同样，完全认为这是非常有效的。是的。但后来出现了一种巨大的，就像钟摆摆动的方式，有那个香蕉女士。她叫什么名字？
Freely. She used to. Girl. Sorry. Girl. Fun fact. She lives still near where I grew up. That's so scary.
Freely。她过去常。天哪。抱歉。天哪。有趣的事实。她仍然住在我长大的地方附近。那太可怕了。
That's so dark-sighted. I know. She lives actually, like, deep in the rainforest of Australia. She always looked like she did. Oh, yeah, yeah. Like deep. all those bananas. I don't know. And now her whole thing is like drinking, okay, no. No, because she just started posting again, didn't she? Yeah. Sorry. Sorry. I'm getting off topic. And with you sharing
那太阴暗了。我知道。她实际上住在澳大利亚雨林的深处。她看起来总是像她那样。哦，是的，是的。就像深处。吃那么多香蕉。我不知道。现在她的全部内容就是喝酒，好吧，不。不，因为她刚开始重新发帖，不是吗？是的。抱歉。抱歉。我跑题了。和你分享
sensitive stuff, I'm sorry. But yeah, so freely the banana go. I think she genuinely not to make, you know, irreputable claims, but triggered a lot of people into a state that was not great. I think so. I think part of the problem was that she was a very visibly thin woman who was like attractive by societal standards and was also had the craziest fucking diet you've ever seen. Like that was a crazy diet. And so I think it did like push a lot of people like both this sort of rise in veganism and this kind of moral guilt of eating animal byproducts. And then also this rise of like this conventionally attractive person with a crazy diet I think pushed me and I started eating vegan. And again, I have vegan friends who eat very healthily.
敏感的事情，我很抱歉。但是是的，所以Freely那个香蕉女孩。我认为她确实，不是要做出不负责任的声明，而是触发了许多人进入了一种不太好的状态。我想是的。我认为问题的一部分在于她是一个非常明显的瘦女人，按照社会标准很有吸引力，而且还有你见过的最疯狂的饮食。那真是一种疯狂的饮食。所以我认为它确实推动了很多人，既是这种纯素食主义的兴起，也是这种吃动物副产品的道德内疚感。然后还有这种传统上很有吸引力的人带着疯狂饮食的兴起，我认为这推动了我，我开始吃纯素。同样，我有吃得非常健康的纯素朋友。
and eat so well and take care of themselves. I was not doing that. I was, like, restricting, girl. I don't think I had a solid bowel movement for, like, three years. This is the size people don't talk about. People don't talk about it. It's gross. Yeah.
吃得很好，照顾好自己。我当时没有那样做。我当时在限制饮食，天哪。我觉得我有三年没有过正常的排便了。这就是人们不谈论的一面。人们不谈论它。这很恶心。是的。
You eat a salad, you poop a salad. It's like, it's really something. You can put that strap line to this episode. Eat a salad, you poop a salad. Yeah. But, yeah, just like in general, it was just like I, again, it became this way. of controlling. And then it became also this like moral thing as well where people associated me on the internet with like eating vegan food. And I don't think it was healthy either because I think
你吃沙拉，你拉出沙拉。这真的很特别。你可以把那句话作为这一集的标题。吃沙拉，你拉出沙拉。是的。但是，是的，总的来说，这就像我，再次，它成为了这种控制的方式。然后它也变成了一种道德上的事情，人们在互联网上把我与吃纯素食物联系起来。而且我认为这也不健康，因为我认为
I was too thin at that point. And I was showing other girls that the way to be thin, poop yourself every day was by eating vegan. And like I wasn't doing it well. I wasn't giving like whole meals. I wasn't showing people how to do it right. I was just, you know, picking the thing that was the most vegan on a menu, even if it was like the cucumber salad with no protein and no carbs and nothing but a cucumber, you know? So that's kind of like where I was like, I kind of need to do something else with this because I'm having headaches all the time and I'm really tired and I guess I'm pooping. Yeah.
那时我太瘦了。我向其他女孩展示了变瘦的方法，每天拉出你自己，就是通过吃纯素。而且我做得并不好。我没有提供完整的膳食。我没有向人们展示如何正确地做。我只是，你知道，在菜单上挑选最纯素的东西，即使它是黄瓜沙拉，没有蛋白质，没有碳水化合物，除了黄瓜什么都没有，你知道吗？所以这就是我当时的想法，我需要用这个做点别的，因为我一直头痛，而且我真的很累，我想我在排便。是的。
So, and you know, I think I really messed up my digestive system. That's the other thing that like people don't really talk about is like even now to this day I have so many digestive issues because of all the eating, the disordered eating that I was doing in my developmental years from when I was like 14 or 13 even until, you know, maybe six years ago. Yeah. Yeah. Well, it is a big thing, right?
所以，你知道，我想我真的搞砸了我的消化系统。这是人们不怎么谈论的另一件事，即使到现在，因为我在发育时期，从我14岁或13岁甚至直到，你知道，也许六年前所做的所有饮食失调，我仍然有很多消化问题。是的。是的。嗯，这是一个大问题，对吧？
Your stomach starts to eat itself, basically. Totally. Which is, again, like, I think a lot of people, and these days with skinny talk, it's like, you just don't understand what you're doing to your body long time. Can I actually come back to this, this, what sounds like kind of a big realization for you, which is like, maybe I wasn't doing this the right way? Like, how have you kind of felt about that as you've gotten older, being like, I don't know, not to say you misguided people, but have you ever been like, I don't know, like,
你的胃基本上开始吃掉它自己。完全正确。这又是，我想很多人，在这些日子里谈论瘦身，就像，你只是不明白你对你的身体长期做了什么。我能回到这个，听起来对你来说是一个很大的认识，那就是，也许我没有用正确的方式做这件事？就像，随着年龄的增长，你对这一点有什么感觉，比如，我不知道，不是说你误导了人们，但你有没有觉得，我不知道，比如，
how do you feel about it now? Yeah. Maybe, I don't want to say set an example for other people because I don't think you deserve to feel like guilt about it. But yeah, how do you feel about it? That was like something you live through online. Like, I still, I feel really guilty about certain videos I posted. There was like, I remember there was one video that I posted. It was supposed to be kind of like a clickbait title that then I would flip it on its head.
你现在感觉如何？是的。也许，我不想说为其他人树立榜样，因为我不认为你值得为此感到内疚。但是的，你感觉如何？那是你在线上经历的事情。就像，我仍然，我对某些我发布的视频感到非常内疚。我记得我发布过一个视频。它本意是某种点击诱饵标题，然后我会把它颠倒过来。
And I would be like, you don't need to worry about this because this is stupid. And it was like five ways to look thinner. But it was when you got into the video, I was like, this is so dumb, like the way that people do this. Like these are, I basically like gathered all these different ways that people talk about it online. And then was like, this is how people are trying to look thinner online. Isn't this so silly? Like this is so stupid. Like journalism, like a real, like journalistic video.
我会说，你不需要担心这个，因为这很愚蠢。它就像五种看起来更瘦的方法。但当你进入视频时，我说，这太蠢了，人们这样做的方式。就像这些是，我基本上收集了所有人们在网上谈论它的不同方式。然后说，这就是人们试图在网上看起来更瘦的方式。这不是很傻吗？这太蠢了。就像新闻，就像一个真正的，新闻报道式的视频。
Almost like journalism. Yeah. But I took it down because that video got crazy views. And what I realized in the comments was like my audience at the time was like 19 year old girls. and they weren't reading it the way that I was posting about it, if that makes sense. They saw the title and they clicked it so that they could actually get advice. And I was pushing them into these corners of the internet that were basically Skinny Talk before Skinny Talk existed, Tumblr pages, like talking about stuff.
几乎就像新闻。是的。但我把它删除了，因为那个视频获得了疯狂的浏览量。我意识到在评论中，我当时的受众是19岁的女孩。她们并没有按照我发布的方式去解读它，如果这有意义的话。她们看到了标题，点击了它，以便她们能真正得到建议。而我把她们推向了互联网的那些角落，那些基本上在“瘦身谈话”存在之前就是“瘦身谈话”的地方，Tumblr页面，谈论这些东西。
And like, I didn't even realize it until I got older. And I remember when I first posted that video, I was sort of like, wow, this video is doing really well. It's getting millions of views and like kind of ignored the moral complication of it. And then sounds so crazy, but Amy Poehler had a production company. I think she probably still does. She might run her podcast through it. But I had a meeting with her production company because I was like, would love to just do something with you.
而且，我直到长大后才意识到这一点。我记得当我第一次发布那个视频时，我有点像，哇，这个视频做得很好。它获得了数百万的浏览量，有点忽略了它的道德复杂性。然后听起来很疯狂，但艾米·波勒有一家制作公司。我想她可能还有。她可能通过它运营她的播客。但我与她的制作公司开了一个会，因为我想，我很乐意与你们做点什么。
Anything if you need like a host to do something, whatever. It was just one of those like Hollywood meetings that I was having. And I remember I sat down with one person from her production team. And the only thing she said to me as like a 20 year old was she was like, we can't work with you because your content doesn't align with us. And I was like, what? What do you mean? My content doesn't align with you. And it was that video.
如果你需要一个主持人来做点什么，任何事情，都可以。这只是我参加的那些好莱坞会议之一。我记得我和她制作团队的一个人坐下来。她作为一个20岁的人对我说的唯一一件事是，她说，我们不能和你合作，因为你的内容与我们不符。我说，什么？你是什么意思？我的内容与你们不符？就是那个视频。
She had seen the thumbnail. She had seen the title of it. And she was like, this girl is promoting eating disorders. Like, this girl is promoting like, yeah. Like, yeah. And so, like, I was so, I remember, like, my stomach dropping and, like, me trying to explain it. And I remember being really mad about it afterwards. But, like, and that was before the era of, like, clickbait titles are the only thing that you read, like, when you only read a headline.
她看到了缩略图。她看到了标题。她说，这个女孩在宣传饮食失调。就像，这个女孩在宣传，是的。就像，是的。所以，我当时，我记得，我的胃下沉，我试图解释它。我记得事后对此感到非常生气。但是，就像，那是在点击诱饵标题是你阅读的唯一东西的时代之前，就像，当你只读标题时。
Right. I feel like now that. that's so prevalent. Like, I'm even bad about that. So I was kind of annoyed at her that she didn't take the time to, like, look at the context of the video. But after that meeting, I immediately went home and took it down. It was like one of my most viewed videos. And I was like, taking that down. And also feeling like so ashamed and so horrible for like, you know, months, but also feeling like righteous fury where I was like, she doesn't even know me. She doesn't even know me. But I was like, that's defensiveness. Like, that was actually probably a good thing that she had
对。我觉得现在那太普遍了。就像，我甚至在这方面很糟糕。所以我有点恼火，她没有花时间去看看视频的背景。但在那次会议之后，我立即回家把它删除了。那是我浏览量最高的视频之一。我当时想，删除它。而且也感到非常羞愧和可怕，持续了几个月，但也感到一种正义的愤怒，我当时想，她甚至不了解我。她甚至不了解我。但我当时想，那是防御心理。就像，那实际上可能是一件好事，她对我说了那些话，因为我很高兴我有机会修复它，如果这有意义的话。但它非常有趣，因为就像，我看到了你的意图。对。我看到了你的意图，比如如果有人正在经历这个或者正在寻找这个。是的。这有点像一种反向心理，比如，我要引诱他们进来，然后说，不要。
said that to me because I'm really glad that I, like, had a chance to, like, fix that, If that makes sense. But it's so interesting because it's like, I see your intention. Right. I see your intention of being like if somebody is going through this or is going to look for this. Yeah. This is kind of like a reverse psychology thing of like, I'm going to lure them in and be like, don't.
是的。这正是我试图做的。完全正确。但也。它超前于时代。完全正确。但也来自错误的人。我不是那个应该谈论那个时期的人。
Yes. That's exactly what I was trying to do. Exactly. But also. It was ahead of its time. Totally. But also it's coming from the wrong person. I'm not the person that should be talking about that period.
是的。你知道我的意思吗？这是一个有趣的地方，我是他们会听取关于那种事情的人，因为我和他们同龄，而且我看起来像他们。但同时我也不是那个应该提供建议的人。但同时我也和他们同龄，我看起来像他们。是的。这就是重点。
Yeah. You know what I mean? It's this like funny place where I'm the person that they're going to listen to about that kind of thing because I'm their age and I like look like them. but also I'm not the person that should be giving me a place. But also I'm at their age and I look like them. Yes. Like that's the thing.
就像方式。是的。是的。因为在那个时候，你是否公开过你可能正在与饮食失调作斗争的事实？是的。我想那时我在互联网上谈论过很多。是的。
It's like way. Yeah. Yeah. Because at that time had you been open about the fact that you were maybe struggling with disordered eating? Yeah. I think I had talked about that a lot on the internet at that point. Yeah.
就像我想那已经是一件事了。而且我认为那也是很多人开始谈论身体积极性的时候。但后来我也认为我与那部分的共鸣较少，因为我的饮食失调很大程度上，就像我说的，是关于控制。所以它就像，就像一切数字对我来说真的很重要。我的拔毛癖非常严重。就像，你知道，我只是在与我所有的其他心理问题作斗争。
Like I think that had been something. And I think that was also a time when a lot of people were starting to talk about body positivity. But then also I think I resonated less with that because so much of my disorder eating, like I said, was about control. And so it was like, like everything numbers was really important to me. My trichotillomania was really bad. Like, you know, I was just like struggling with all of my other mental problems.
然后，饮食失调是某种程度上重新获得一点控制权的方式，你知道。所以我无法真正理解。我不知道。我觉得我是从一个，我觉得这是一个非常个人的角度。而实际上，这就是很多人处理饮食失调的方式。就像，这是一种非常普遍的被引入饮食失调的方式，比如缺乏控制。但这确实让我大开眼界，看到了身体中立可能是什么样子。那似乎是。
And then like, then the eating disorder was the way to kind of like gain a bit of control back, you know. So I couldn't really understand. Like, I don't know. I feel like I was coming at it from like a like a, I felt like it was a really like personal angle. When in reality that's how like a lot of people deal with eating disorders. Like that's a very common. common way to be introduced into an eating disorder is like lacking control. But it definitely opened my eyes like to what like body neutrality could look like. And that seemed to be.
那是自由。真心话。每个人都尝试身体积极性是可以的。身体中立是最好的。我真的很喜欢它。我可以把我的牙齿咬进去。哦，它很美味。是的。吃掉它。哦，是的。随着年龄的增长，我想这也是另一件事，就是我想我也喜欢在好莱坞，去参加试镜之类的，因为我从16岁起就开始试镜和表演了。所以我去，就像，这就是我最初在YouTube上稍微变大的原因，因为我被这个叫Awesomeist TV的节目选中了，它就像。哦，天哪。
That's freedom. Genuinely. Everybody tries to body positive is fine. Body neutrality is the best. I really love it. I could stick my teeth into that. Oh, it's delicious. Yeah. Eat that up. Oh yeah. And as I get older, I think that's the other thing too is like I think I also like being in Hollywood and going on auditions and stuff because I was auditioning and I was acting from when I was 16. So I would go, like, that's how I originally kind of got slightly bigger on YouTube was because I got picked up by this, like, show called Awesomeist TV, which was like. Oh my goodness.
闪回。我记得那个。他们会在YouTube上做所有这些电视节目，对吧？我想它是由尼克国际儿童频道支持的。是的，是的。所以它基本上就像是针对青少年的，就像尼克国际儿童频道一直做得很好，制作青少年内容一样。他们试图为YouTube用户这样做。所以我成为了，我住在离工作室很近的地方，就像离工作室很近。
Flashback. I remember that. And they would do like all these TV shows, but on YouTube, right? It was like, I think it was backed by Nickelodeon. Yeah, yeah. And so it was basically like supposed to be like a tween, like in the same way that Nickelodeon has always done a really good job of making tween content. They tried to do that for YouTubers. So I became, and I lived like down the studio, like down the road from the studio.
所以我过去常常步行去上班，和他们一起拍摄剧集等等。但那作为我的跳板，我开始试镜并做所有这些事情。作为一个21岁，20岁的人，你的身体，你的外表，一切都被批评。就像我记得走进试镜室，他们会直接关掉摄像机。就像他们甚至不会，就像，他们会让我完成整个过程，然后我会看，我会意识到摄像机从来没有开过，因为我只是不符合那个形象。这没关系。但每次都会发生某种自我死亡。所以我认为那也只是，我在那种情况下也是一个独特的情况。我认为这是如果你不在行业中就不会知道的事情，这是一个题外话。哦，在娱乐行业或切线是，总是有一种想法，比如，如果我更瘦，我会更成功吗？完全正确。完全正确。我想过那个。我一直都在想。是的。不，完全正确。而且它也像，我认为它，再次，它有点像一个控制问题，因为
And so I used to just walk to work to like film episodes with them and da-da-da-da. But that being kind of like my jump off point, I started auditioning and doing all this stuff. And being critiqued as like a 21 year old, a 20-year-old on your body, your looks, like everything. Like I remember walking into auditions where they would just like immediately turn off the camera. Like they wouldn't even, like, they would let me go through with the whole thing and then I would look and I would realize the camera was never on because I was just not the look. And that's fine. But there's just like an ego death that happens like every time. So I think that was also just like, I was in a unique circumstance in that way as well. I think this is something that you wouldn't know unless you were in industries that a tangent. Oh, in entertainment industry or tangential is like there is always this thought of like, would I be more successful if I was skinnier. Totally. Totally. I have thought about that. I think about that all. time. Yeah. No, completely. And it's also like, I think it's, again, it's kind of a control issue because
当你处于那样的行业中，没有任何东西在你的控制之下时，你不是那个可以让妈妈和爸爸打电话确保有人真的在房间里关注你或者在名单上看到你的名字的“星二代”。所以如果有什么你可以控制的，那就是背台词和挨饿。就像那似乎是我当时认为我有控制权的两件事，其实不然。而且如果你很瘦，每个人都会看着你。就像，这就是重点。就像你会更受关注。
when you're in industries like that where there is literally nothing else is in your control, you are not the NEPO baby that can have the like mom and dad call to make sure that like someone actually pays attention to you in a room or like sees your name on a sheet. So if there is anything that you can control, it's learning your lines and starving yourself. Like that seems to be like the two things that at the time I thought I had control over, which is not. And if you're thin, everybody's going to look at you. Like, that's the thing. It's like you're going to be noticed more.
是的。这真是一个头脑。是的。这很有趣，因为我想那个。然后我想，因为有时我想，如果我现在处于同样的情况，我会做什么。我想，我实际上认为我会看起来独特得多。而且如果我只是，非常正常，我想我会更适合被选角。我想如果我只是，非常正常，我可以让那些“星二代”成为，非常火辣、瘦削的人。
Yeah. It's such a mind. Yeah. It's funny, though, because I think that. And then I think about, like, because sometimes I think about, like, what I would do now if I was in that same situation. I'm like, I actually think I would have looked a lot more unique. And I think I would have been a lot more castable had I just been, like, very normal. I think if I had just been, like, very normal, I could let the Nepo babies be, like, the really hot, thin people.
然后我可以成为那个正常的女孩，这通常是我无论如何都会被选中的角色。是的。所以你这些天还演戏吗？不，不。你是否有点像，我受够了？我有点受够了。再次，我不断回到这个控制问题。但就像，即使你确实被选中了，也有很大的机会那个选你的人是一个以某种方式喜欢你的男人。所以它只是，我不知道。就像我丈夫是一名电影制作人、作家和导演。所以他完全参与其中。而且就像，我现在喜欢写作方面的事情。是的。有趣。是的。
and then I could be like the normal girl, which is usually what I got cast for anyways. Yeah. So do you do much acting these days? No, no. Have you kind of been like, I'm done with that? I'm kind of done with it. Again, I keep coming back to this problem of control. But like, even when you do get cast, there's like a very good chance the person who
而且我一直说，就像，我会再次演戏，但前提是我对它有很大的控制权。是的。我，就像，非常享受。我有幸在一部喜剧中工作了四年。那真的很棒。它太有趣了。是的，它真的很酷。它有点，就像，被扔进了历史的垃圾桶，因为它就像，它是为那些
cast you is like a man who likes you in some way. And so it's just like, it's just not, I don't know. Like my husband's a filmmaker and a writer and a director. So he is totally in on that. And like, I love the writing side of things now. Yeah. Interesting. Yeah.
应用程序之一制作的，它的每一集的运行时间都有点奇怪。就像它不是半小时，也不是分成四分之一。所以它是一个很难定位的奇怪节目。那部喜剧是什么？它叫《Mr. Student Body President》。哦，天哪，《Mr. Student Body President》。好吧，每个人都去给这个女人一些版税。
And I've always said, like, I would do acting again, but only if I had, like, a lot of control over it. Yeah. I, like, so enjoyed. I got to work on a comedy for four years. That was really amazing. It was so fun. Yeah, it was really, really cool. It kind of got, like, put into the bin of history because it was, like, it was for one of
我不知道它在哪里播放。我不知道我是否曾经为此获得过版税，但如果你能找到它。但是那个家伙，我的好朋友Jeremy Sheda，他是《探险活宝》中Finn的配音演员，他是主角。所以我成为了，就像，和他成为了非常好的朋友，因为我们在过去四年里经常在一起玩。所以这就像是会发生的非常好的事情。是的。与那些糟糕的事情同时发生。真的很糟糕的事情。是的。是的。是的。这太有道理了。你知道吗？过渡到下一个问题非常顺畅，因为这就是我接下来要问你的，那就是你与媒体、社交媒体和你的职业生涯的关系如何？近年来事情发生了怎样的变化？你是否感到更渴望上网？就像我肯定有一段时间你是一名演员，你有点像，也许我不应该上网那么多，也许我应该有这种更专业的外表，就像我在替你说话。这对你来说发生了怎样的变化？我想我会诚实，因为我从还是个孩子的时候就开始做社交媒体，我做它就像没有赚钱，而且非常享受它，它就像我的情感释放。它就像我的社交释放，它给了我所有的朋友。它给了我我的未来，所有这些美妙的事情。
those, like, apps where it has, like, a weird timing of, like, runtime for, each episode. Like, it wasn't a half hour and it wasn't split into quarters. So it was kind of a weird one to place. What was the comedy? It was called Mr. Student Body President. Oh my God, Mr. Student Body President. Okay, everybody go and give this woman some royalties.
我有一段时间不想再做了，因为我讨厌这种想法，就像我现在做这个只是为了赚钱。就像那种在赚钱和发布真实内容之间的反向关系，变得非常不平衡。是的。我当时想，我做这个是因为我需要付房租。我做这个不是因为我一定想发布这些东西。是的。是的，它有点到了那个地步。而且我对此有过起伏。
I have no idea where it's playing. I don't know if I've ever gotten a royalty for it, but if you can find it. But the guy, my good friend Jeremy Sheda, who's the voice of Finn from Adventure Time, he was the lead. So I became, like, really good friends with him because we hung out so much for the last, like, four years. So it was like really good things that would happen. Yeah. In tandem with like the shit stuff. Really terrible stuff. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That makes so much sense. And you know what? The segways into the next questions have been so smooth because this is what I was
而且我认为当涉及到表演的事情时，我一直非常喜欢，我对此非常有热情。而且我把它看作是一种艺术形式，显然。电影制作是一种艺术形式。如果有一个世界，我真的可以做到这一点并赚钱，并且在其中感到安全，我想我会把我的手机扔进大海，再也不会发布任何东西了。但这也不现实，因为那没有发生。那就像一个，你知道，回顾性的幻想。但我认为现在，我认为那不是事情会发生的方式。是的，就像我想我可能还是会发布东西。只是因为你太喜欢它了？是的。是的。是的。而且我，我是一个大嘴巴，正如你所看到的。
going to ask you about next, which is like how is your relationship to like the media and social media and your career? Like how have things changed in recent years? Have you felt more of a desire to be online? Like I'm sure there was a period when you were an actor. where you were kind of like maybe I shouldn't be online as much like maybe I should have this more professional look like I'm putting words in your mouth. How is it how has it changed for you? I think I'm going to be honest because I did social media from when I was a kid and I did it like without earning money and enjoyed it so much and it was like my emotional release. It was like my social release and it gave me like all my friends. It gave me my future like all these amazing things.
这就是我所说的。你需要开始你的播客。这是终极媒介。大嘴巴。是的，这太棒了。所以你认为你会余生都继续发布吗？这是人们问我的事情。可能吧，是的。
I stopped wanting to do it for a while because I hated the idea that like I was just doing this now to make money. Like that that like that inverse relationship between like making money and posting on like authentic content like became really unbalanced. Yeah. Where I was like I'm doing this because I need to like make my rent. I'm not doing this because I necessarily want to be posting these things. Yeah. Yeah, it kind of got to that point. And I've had like ebbs and flows of that.
是的。就像，这不会让我感到震惊。是的。嗯，因为也像，不是要过早地过渡。不。但因为你在为我做我的工作，这就是我所说的。那么你今天过得怎么样？你在看……
And I think when it came to the acting stuff, I always really loved the, I was really passionate about it. And I think of it as like an art form, obviously. And filmmaking is an art form. And if there was ever a world where I could have actually done that and made money and like felt secure in that, I think I would have thrown my phone into the ocean and like never posted anything ever again. But that's just also not realistic because that didn't happen. And that's like a, you know, like a retrospective fantasy. But I think nowadays, I think that's like not how that would have gone. Yeah, like I think I probably still would have posting stuff. Just because you loved it so much? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And I'm like, I'm a blabbermouth, as you can tell.
所以当我想要过渡到下一个时，我现在意识到它有多重要。而且我从有点怨恨觉得这是我赚钱的唯一方式。因为我也不是大学毕业。我没有上大学。我……那个决定是怎么回事，快点？嗯，我……
This is what I'm saying. You need to start on your podcast. It's the ultimate medium. Blabber mouth. Yeah, it's amazing. So do you think you're going to keep posting for like the rest of your life? This is something people ask me. Probably, yeah.
嗯，好吧。所以这太有趣了，因为它就像是2008年奥巴马时代保守派所珍视的政治泡沫。是的。嗯，也就是，实际上，我们不再喜欢大学了。反智主义开始流行起来。而且，嗯，这太有趣了，因为我的三个兄弟姐妹都受过高等教育，其中两个读了研究生。所以我像，我不知道我是从哪里，其中一个读了法学院，一个读了研究生。所以我像，我不知道我到底是怎么成为那个的。但我认为部分原因是我的父母就像我们中产阶级的阿肯色人。他们就像，
Yeah. Like, it wouldn't shock me. Yeah. Well, because also like, not to like segue way too early. No. But because you are doing my job for me and it is this is what I'm saying. So how's your day been to that? Are you looking at the...
哦，其中一个不想上大学。那挺酷的。而且她已经在赚钱了。就像我爸爸是那个会飞我到洛杉矶，并在我做Awesomeist TV之类的事情时陪着我的人。而且就像当我为Awesomeist TV得到这些小报酬时，我每周能得到600美元，就像在周末去工作。然后。那很低。巨大。对一个青少年来说巨大。是的。
So as I'm wanting to segue way into the next now, I've just realized how important it is. And like I've gone from being kind of resentful of feeling like this is the only way that I can make money. Because also I'm not college educated. I didn't go to college. Like I... What was that decision like quickly? Well, I...
但就像对一个青少年来说巨大，但对生活来说不是。是的。不。是的。完全正确。但就像在我的脑海里。在周末工作，做所有这些疯狂的事情。哦，是的。
Well, okay. So it's so funny because it's like it's the political burblings of like what you're conservatives were valuing in like 2008 Obama era. Yeah. Um, which was like, actually, we don't like college anymore. Like the anti-intellectualism kind of started popping off. But also, um, it's so funny because all three of my siblings are really highly educated, like two of them went to grad school. So I'm like, I don't know where one of them went to law school and one of went to grad school. So I'm like, I don't know where the hell I became the one. But also I think part of it was that my parents were like our like middle class Arkansasans. And they were like,
哦，是的。所以对一个青少年来说。就像，哇。完全正确。而且话虽如此，那是一个月一次。所以是一个月600美元。是的。被飞过去。
oh, one of them doesn't want to go to college. That's kind of cool. And she's already making money. And like my dad was the one who would fly me to L.A. and like be with me when I would do like the awesome as TV stuff. And like when I would get these little for awesmith TV, I was getting $600 a week to like come in on the weekend. And then. That is low. Huge. Huge for a teenager. Yeah.
而且我认为这是世界上最迷人的事情。而且确实是。但就像，我当时想，我有我自己的钱。我可以付房租，因为我一直在存钱。钱。就像我没有，我在阿肯色州小石城把钱花在什么上了？所以我只是，就像，存下我所有的钱。所以我从16岁到18岁有这个小小的积蓄，能够付房租等等。所以我申请了纽约大学。而且我申请了加州大学洛杉矶分校。而那是我申请的仅有的两所学校。我在加州大学洛杉矶分校被列入候补名单。而且我没有被纽约大学录取。所以我当时想，
But like huge for a teenage, but not for life. Yeah. No. Yeah. Totally. But like in my head. Working in the weekends, like doing all this crazy stuff. Oh yeah.
好吧，我想我要飞到加利福尼亚看看会发生什么。因为就像，也许我会进入加州大学洛杉矶分校。也许他们会，哦，认为那会发生真是太甜了。我实际上很喜欢那个。我喜欢你当时就像大大学。是的。我当时想，他们会让我进去的。是的。他们不知道我是谁吗？他们没看过Awesomeist TV吗？拜托。但是是的，所以我最终在Park La Brea这个地方租了一间非常糟糕的公寓。它在洛杉矶的哪个部分？它是，好吧。如果你了解洛杉矶，你就会知道这个地方。它是，如果你去参观，你就会知道它。它在西好莱坞。好的。或者它在好莱坞。而且它就在Grove旁边。它就像，就在路边。那些总是说，便宜公寓，便宜
Oh yeah. And so it is for a teenager. Like, wow. Totally. And also that being said, it would be once a month. So it was $600 a month. Yeah. To get flown out.
公寓的巨大塔楼。它们便宜的原因，据称，是因为它们绝对，我无法告诉你多少蟑螂和多少臭虫。哦，天哪。臭虫是那个。蟑螂我可以忍受，臭虫。疯狂。也许可能不会。不，听着，你可以和蟑螂住在一起，直到它们开始从你的水龙头里出来，就像恐怖电影一样。就像它是一个阴险的，相当阴险的。而且，我关于这些公寓不了解的另一件事，抱歉，我正在随机。我喜欢，请。但它们也，它们的窗户太高了。我住在30楼。
And I thought it was the most glamorous thing in the entire world. And it was. But like, I was like, I've got my own money. I could pay rent because I had been saving all my money. money. Like I wasn't, what was I spending my money on in Little Rock, Arkansas? So I would just, like, save all my money. So I had this, like, little fat pad from when I was 16 until I was like 18 to be able to get rent and da-da-da-da. And so I applied to NYU. And I applied to UCLA. And those are the only two schools that I applied to. And I got waitlisted at UCLA. And I didn't get into NYU. So I was like,
而且窗户上没有纱窗。哦，天哪。你是在要求有人摔下去。哦，天哪。就像，有人可能只是，就像，摔过去。这太疯狂了。疯狂。它总是让我感到害怕。
well, I guess I'm going to fly to California and see what happens. Because like, maybe I'll get into UCLA. Maybe they'll, oh, so sweet to think that that was going to happen. I actually love that. I love that you were like the big uni's. Yeah. I was like, they're going to let me in. Yeah. Do they don't know who I am? Have they not seen awesome this TV? Come on. But yeah, so I ended up getting like a really shitty apartment at this place called Park La Brea. What part of L.A. is it in? It's, okay. If you know L.A., you will know this place. It is, and if you visit, you will know it. It's, it's in West Hollywood. Okay. Or it's in Hollywood. And it's right by the grove. It's like, right down the road. It's those giant towers that are always saying, like, cheap apartments, cheap
是的。就像，你知道，就像，我想这就是我对高度的恐惧来源的地方。你知道，当你，就像，俯视非常非常高的地方，你就像，我现在可能会从这里掉下去。或者就像我可以跳下去。就像盯着那个看有一些东西。我记得我在公寓里经常那样做，不是像那种令人毛骨悚然的方式，
apartments. The reason why they're cheap, allegedly, is because they are absolutely, I can't tell you how many cockroaches and how many bedbugs. Oh my God. The bedbugs are the one. Cockroaches I can live with bedbugs. Crazy. Maybe probably not. No, listen, you can live with a cockroach until they start coming out of your faucet, like a horror movie. Like it is a devious, quite devious. And also, the other thing I didn't understand about these apartments, sorry, I'm going on a random. I love, please. But they also, their windows were so high. I lived on the 30th floor.
而是就像一种，就像，我真的不希望那样发生。就像我一直做梦梦到不小心从窗户滑出去。我觉得那非常令人兴奋，说实话。就像这种围绕着，是的，它可能会发生。它可能会发生。有什么，我过去常有这种想法，我会想，有什么说我昨天实际上没有，而这只是它的一部分。无论如何，我们不会得到那个。
And the windows didn't have screens on them. Oh, my God. You're asking for someone to take a tumble. Oh, my God. Like, somebody could just have an, like, fall through. That is crazy. Crazy. It always freaked me out.
哇。抱歉，不应该把那个放进人们的脑子里。哇。哦，我得到了。哦，我下次有一些。以后再琢磨。我知道。好吧，希望你不住在30楼。
Yeah. Like, you know, like, I think that's where my fear, like, a large fear of, like, heights has come from. You know, when you're, like, looking over something really, really high and you're like, I could just fall off of this right now. Or like I could just jump. Like there's something about staring like into that that. That I remember doing that a lot when I was in my apartment, not like in a creepy way,
不，想在三楼。好多了。非常多。安全。对此非常高兴。安全。是的。骄傲就像爱。
but just in like a like, like, I really don't want that to happen. Like I kept like having dreams about accidentally slipping out of the window. I feel like that's very ericited to be real with you. Like this obsession around like yeah, it could happen. It could happen. What's to, I used to have this where I'd be like, what's to say that I actually didn't for yesterday and this is just bit of it. Anyways, we'll not get that.
你在心里感受到它。I-R-Radio。加拿大排名第一的广播和播客流媒体应用程序，包括I-Hart Pride Canada，你最喜欢的热门歌曲和必备派对金曲，加上个性化和精选的播放列表。就像过去的骄傲。聚在一起，庆祝爱。随身携带骄傲。随时随地。
Whoa. Sorry, should not put that in people's heads. Whoa. Oh, I got. Oh, I got some next time. to mull over later. I know. Well, hopefully you don't live on a 30 floor.
只需让你的智能音箱播放IHart Pride Canada。在你的手机上流媒体播放我们。好吧，现在听。在那一刻，感觉它好像永远在持续。我以为我活不下去了。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变成了黑色。
No, think on third floor. Way better. Very much. Safe. Way happier about that. Safe. Yeah. Pride is like love.
它把我吓坏了。那是你的第一个谋杀案？是的，先生。敢说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件？是的，先生。强奸谋杀一个孩子，一个孩子。尽可能糟糕。我想也是。
You feel it in your heart. I-R-Radio. Canada's number one streaming app for radio and podcasts, including I-Hart Pride Canada, your favorite hits and must-have party bangers, plus personalized and curated playlists. Like back-in-the-day pride. Come together, celebrate love. Take pride with you. Anytime, anywhere.
你能在心中感受到它。I-R-Radio。加拿大排名第一的广播和播客流媒体应用，包括I-Hart Pride Canada，这里有你最喜爱的热门歌曲和必备派对金曲，以及个性化和精心策划的播放列表。就像往昔的骄傲庆典一样。聚在一起，庆祝爱。随身携带这份骄傲。随时随地。
Just ask your smart speaker to play IHart Pride Canada. Stream us on your phone. Well, and listen now. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black.
只需让你的智能音箱播放IHart Pride Canada。在手机上收听我们。嗯，现在就听。在那一刻，感觉仿佛持续了永恒。我以为我活不成了。我吓坏了。那双眼睛里空无一物。它们变成了黑色。
It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child, a child. as bad as it gets. I would think so.
这把我吓坏了。那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，长官。可以说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件吗？是的，长官。强奸并谋杀了一个孩子，一个孩子。这是最糟糕的情况了。我想是这样。
Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Creveit and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
邪恶，醒醒。我就是那个目睹了克雷维特和德皮波谋杀案的人。安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后毫无悔意，表现得泰然自若。我说我没有罪。我会把这个秘密带进坟墓。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《魔鬼的采石场》。
And to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content, And subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression.
想要收听无广告版《魔鬼的采石场》并获取独家内容，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅“Love for Good Plus”。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》的主持人。我们将与世界上最迷人的人进行有意义的对话。比如女演员奥利维亚·穆恩分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战时说：“我经历过乳腺癌，后来又帮助我母亲对抗乳腺癌，那更困难。有很多人了解产后抑郁症。”
I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Because their new star is Javier T. Torito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death?
我当时对产后焦虑毫无准备。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》。因为他们的新星是哈维尔·T·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我视为足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我都在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情绪共处。我仍然有很多问题。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？
How do you deal with cancellation? Christiano or Messi Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barza From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary This isn't a normal podcast
你如何应对被取消？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨？从日常平凡到深邃非凡，这不是一个普通的播客。
Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine This podcast is like a deep talk With your closest friends Where vulnerability comes out Conspiracy theories End up on the table And goals and lessons are shared All in this life
这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行深度交谈，在这里展现脆弱，阴谋论被摆上台面，目标和人生经验被分享，这一切都在此生中。
has an order perfect and all is just Wait, wait me, I'm here to put We are here to connect The Chicharito I'm Javier Licharito Hernandez, and together with IHard Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It is a crack.
有着完美的秩序，一切都只是……等等，等等我，我在这里是为了……我们在这里是为了建立联系。我是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯，与iHeart Radio一起，我们将让平凡变得非凡。保持关注。他是个天才。
Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Keith Gianmanca seemed like a mild-mannered suburban dad, but secretly, he became someone else, a master of disguise who went on a crime spree. At the time, did it seem like a crazy idea? It seemed very crazy, but I felt so desperate that I felt it was the quickest, easiest way out. Did you allow yourself to think about how it could go wrong on what that might look like? No, I didn't want to manifest that. I was trying to manifest success.
哇。请在iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。基思·吉安曼卡看起来像个温文尔雅的郊区父亲，但私下里，他变成了另一个人，一个擅长伪装并开始犯罪狂潮的人。当时，这看起来是个疯狂的想法吗？看起来非常疯狂，但我感到如此绝望，以至于我觉得这是最快、最简单的出路。你有没有让自己去想如果事情搞砸了会怎样，或者那会是什么样子？不，我不想预示那种结果。我试图预示成功。
Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? that is not the look of an innocent man. This is going to change my life and my family dynamic forever because everything that had existed prior in my reality is now untrue. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. How's your career? What are you doing now? I feel like you're kind of in this period of starting fresh.
每个家庭都有秘密。但当你发现你的父亲一直过着双重生活时会发生什么？那不是一个无辜者的眼神。这将永远改变我的生活和家庭动态，因为我现实中之前存在的一切现在都不真实了。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Deep Cover: The Family Man》。你的事业怎么样？你现在在做什么？我觉得你正处于一个重新开始的时期。
Yeah. What does it like to start afresh as like you enter 30? Yeah, it's, I think it's been like a cool, that's been really, it's felt like an appropriate time to start something new, you know, like, yeah, a turning over of a leaf, really. Especially since like turning 30 is the time when you're supposed to like shrivel up and turn into like an old hag and I don't know, maybe start performing hexes on people. I don't know what like the general consensus is. It sounds fun. I'm already doing that. So I'm already way ahead of you guys.
是的。当你进入30岁时，重新开始是什么感觉？是的，我觉得这很酷，这感觉是一个开始新事物的合适时机，你知道，就像，真的翻开了新的一页。特别是30岁被认为是你应该枯萎并变成一个老巫婆的时候，我不知道，也许开始对人施咒。我不知道大众的共识是什么。听起来很有趣。我已经那样做了。所以我已经领先你们很多了。
But I think it's just like funny to like step across the threshold of 30 and not like immediately pass away. You seem pretty healthy. You seem you seem happy. I'm feeling really good. Yeah. And I think that's the secret is that and my mother-in-law has told me this because she was like was and is the most fabulous woman. But she was like your 30s are like the best years of your life easily. And then she was like, but actually your 40s are the best year.
但我认为跨过30岁的门槛而不立即去世是很有趣的。你看上去很健康。你看上去很开心。我感觉真的很好。是的，我认为秘诀就在于此，我婆婆告诉过我，因为她曾经是，现在也是最棒的女人。但她说你的30多岁是你一生中最美好的时光，轻而易举。然后她说，但实际上你的40多岁才是最好的。
But actually your 50s year. Like it only gets better, I think, for women as we get older. I've heard this. Yeah, like I really do. I've heard this. And I feel that. Like, I feel it in my bone. How old are you? I'm 26 now. Oh my God, it's only going to get so much better. You know what? I also feel like I've documented my entire 20s. Yeah. So I've literally been doing this podcast since I was 21. That's so crazy. So I honestly think that 30 is going to be a, not like a liberation, but like a whole new chapter. I don't know to go. Yeah. Yeah. To make this about me. But like I just think it's going to be, you know, I turn 30. It's like a new. a new chapter of life that maybe I don't document and I do just get to live and like so many things that I know it's very transformative just like I'm excited again and maybe it's also my OCD but like having a number where I'm like oh this is when things start or whatever it was like very freeing for me like before I left L.A. I was 28 and I was like I feel really sad that I haven't oil painted in like a really, really long time. Like I hadn't done an oil painting in probably
但实际上是50多岁。我觉得对女性来说，随着年龄增长，一切只会变得更好。我听说过这个。是的，我真的这么认为。我听说过。我能感觉到。我骨子里能感觉到。你多大了？我现在26岁。天哪，只会变得越来越好。你知道吗？我也觉得我记录了我的整个20多岁。是的。所以我真的从21岁起就开始做这个播客了。太疯狂了。所以我真心认为30岁将是一个，不是像一种解放，而是一个全新的篇章。我不知道该去哪里。是的。是的。为了把这变成关于我的事。但我只是觉得它会是，你知道，我30岁了。这就像一个新的，人生的新篇章，也许我不记录它，我只是去生活，还有很多我知道的事情，这非常有变革性，就像我又感到兴奋了，也许这也是我的强迫症，但有一个数字让我觉得，哦，这就是事情开始的时候，或者无论它是什么，这对我来说非常自由。在我离开洛杉矶之前，我28岁，我感到非常难过，因为我已经很久很久没有画油画了。就像我可能已经有
10 years. And I used to do like semi-competitive oil painting in high school, if that's a thing. Everything can be competitive. Everything can be competitive. If you're a high achiever. Yeah, if you try hard enough. But I used to do these conservation paintings for this thing in Arkansas called the 4-H Center, where it was like a fish and wildlife conservation. And so I used to do these like hyper-realistic oil paintings of endangered species. And sometimes charcoal, sometimes chalk pastel, but I would just like do these. Like I learned how to kind of like replicate nature in a way that was really cool. And I was really competitive. So that was something that I did all throughout high school. And I loved it. It got to the point where I had from the little bit of money that I had been making
10年没画油画了。我在高中时曾经进行过半竞技性的油画创作，如果那算的话。一切都可以是竞技性的。一切都可以是竞技性的。如果你是一个追求卓越的人。是的，如果你足够努力的话。但我曾经为阿肯色州一个叫4-H中心的地方做这些保护画，那是关于鱼类和野生动物保护的。所以我曾经做这些濒危物种的超写实油画。有时用木炭，有时用粉笔，但我只是做这些。就像我学会了如何以一种非常酷的方式复制自然。而且我非常有竞争力。所以这是我整个高中时期都在做的事情。我喜欢它。到了后来，我用我赚的一点点钱
from Austin's TV. I had asked my art teacher if I could come to her studio that she would work out of with all these other like cool adult artists. And I basically got a little corner of her studio with my friend Sarah who also wanted to do the same thing. And we would oil paint together like in this like adult studio and it felt so cool like, you know, to come on a Thursday and like oil paint. So anyways, but that was like such a positive memory for me and something where I really got into flow state. And then as I got older and I was living in tinier studio apartments, I was like, I just don't have room for this. And so I. So I was. So I. I would just put it off and put it off and put it off.
从奥斯汀的电视节目中赚的钱。我问我的美术老师我是否可以去她的工作室，她和其他那些很酷的成年艺术家一起工作。我基本上和我的朋友莎拉一起在她的工作室里得到了一个小角落，她也想做同样的事情。我们会像在成人工作室里一样一起画油画，感觉太酷了，你知道，周四来画油画。总之，这对我是个非常积极的记忆，也是我真正进入心流状态的事情。然后随着我长大，住在更小的单间公寓里，我想，我只是没有空间做这个。所以我。所以我。我只是推迟了又推迟，推迟了又推迟。
And I would do, you know, like, watercolor paintings. I would do anything that was, like, not messy in my apartment. And then when I got to the point where I was living in L.A. and I could, like, buy my own house. I bought a house and still didn't oil paint, even though I had the space for it. And I was like, well, this is, like, stupid. Like, you're just, you've literally created a barrier for yourself. And now you're just not breaking it because you are nervous about being bad.
我会做，你知道，比如水彩画。我会做任何在我的公寓里不脏乱的事情。然后当我住在洛杉矶，可以买自己的房子时。我买了一栋房子，但仍然没有画油画，尽管我有空间。我想，好吧，这太蠢了。就像你，你实际上为自己制造了一个障碍。而现在你只是没有打破它，因为你担心自己会画得很烂。
Like, because it's been so long. It was like I had such a competitive spirit for it when I was younger that the idea of going back to something and being bad at it immediately because I was going to be bad. Oh, yeah. Like that's just how it's going to be. But what a how liberating. Yeah, exactly. To be crap and just get a try. Be bad.
因为已经过去太久了。就像我年轻时对它有很强的竞争精神，以至于回到某件事并立即表现得很差的想法，因为我肯定会表现得很差。哦，是的。就像事情本来就会那样。但这多令人解放啊。是的，完全正确。表现得很烂，然后试一试。表现得很差。
Just try. And so then when I started painting again, I started recording myself painting and kind of told the story of what I just told you, which is that I used to really love doing this. And then I felt really like a lot of shame around being bad at it eventually. And so kind of trying to like re-invigorate my like artistic side of myself. And that also coincided with us realizing that we were going to be very kind of last minute and unexpectedly going to be moving to London. Wait, that was just like a last minute, a quick decision. That was something that was we knew was going to probably happen in like the next couple years. But for like unforeseen personal reasons, it ended up being.
试一试就好。所以当我开始重新画画时，我开始录下自己画画的过程，并讲述了我刚才告诉你的故事，那就是我曾经非常喜欢做这件事。然后我最终对表现得很差感到非常羞愧。所以试图重新激发我艺术的一面。这也恰逢我们意识到我们将非常仓促且出乎意料地搬到伦敦。等等，那只是一个仓促的、快速的决定。那是我们知道可能在未来几年内会发生的事情。但由于一些不可预见的个人原因，最终变成了。
like I had like two and a half months of like, oh, I think we're moving. And then it was like, oh, I'm trying to get my visa now. Like, oh, we're like in process. And I was kind of in denial of it the whole time that it was happening. I don't know. It was just like all these things like that felt very like left behind because even like when I bought my house, I bought basically half a house, which is like so weird to say, but it was like under construction. Oh, really?
就像我有两个半月的时间，哦，我想我们要搬家了。然后就像，哦，我现在在申请签证。就像，哦，我们正在办理中。我整个过程中一直处于否认状态。我不知道。这就像所有这些事情，感觉非常像被抛在后面，因为即使当我买房子时，我基本上买了一半的房子，说出来很奇怪，但它正在建设中。哦，真的吗？
Yeah, because that's what I could afford in the area. But my dad's a builder. And so I was like, I'm going to be the person that like can make money off this house because I'm going to flip it. Like I'm going to do it. And then I'm going to live in it. And I'm going to feel. And then everything was like $300,000 like minimum for everything. And I was like, cool. So that's just never going to happen. So we ended up living in kind of like half a house for like the entire time that we were living in LA. That was also praying on me because I was like, oh, this is such a failure. Like I wanted to be able to redo this house and like all these things. And so in the middle of this while I was waiting to get my. visa, I had started oil painting and I started, I went around my neighborhood and I started taking film photos of all of my favorite houses in the neighborhood. And then I set myself up outside and painted my view from my window so that I could see like what my neighborhood looked like when I lived there. And then also did like personal portraits of all of the houses around me.
是的，因为那是我在该地区能负担得起的。但我爸爸是个建筑商。所以我当时想，我将成为那个能从这栋房子里赚钱的人，因为我要把它翻新。我要做这件事。然后我要住进去。我要感觉。然后一切都至少要30万美元。我想，酷。所以这永远不会发生。所以我们最终在我们住在洛杉矶的整个时间里，基本上住在一半的房子里。这也困扰着我，因为我想，哦，这真是一个失败。我想能够重新装修这栋房子，做所有这些事情。所以在这期间，当我等待签证时，我开始画油画，我开始在我的社区里走动，开始拍摄我最喜欢的房子的胶片照片。然后我把自己安置在外面，画出我从窗户看到的景色，这样我就可以看到我住在那儿时社区的样子。然后还为我周围所有的房子画了个人肖像。
And it became like the way that I kind of like exercised that feeling of being sad about leaving and also memorialize them and then also like could kind of tap back into my artistry in a way that felt really like therapeutic. So beautiful. Yeah, it was really nice. But then also I felt really good because somehow I managed to do all of that and film it, which is not normally like that's the other thing about doing art and filming it. And you probably know this.
它变成了我发泄那种离开的悲伤感的方式，同时也纪念它们，然后也能以一种感觉非常治愈的方式重新触及我的艺术性。太美了。是的，真的很好。但我也感觉很好，因为不知何故我设法完成了所有这些并拍摄了下来，这通常不是，这就是做艺术并拍摄它的另一件事。你可能知道这一点。
Like it's it feels like you take a bit of the soul out of it if you have to film it. Yeah. Sometimes. Yeah. But I think because I was so comfortable. like filming myself that I could kind of like get past that and just be like this is another example of being able to hopefully help other people feel like if you haven't done this artistic pursuit whatever that may be for a really long time it's like never too late to come back to
就像如果你必须拍摄它，感觉就像你从中抽走了一点灵魂。是的。有时。是的。但我认为因为我非常习惯拍摄自己，所以我可以克服这一点，只是觉得这是另一个例子，希望能帮助其他人感觉到，如果你已经很久没有做这种艺术追求了，无论那是什么，永远都不晚，回来做它，表现得很差，所以我认为这就是YouTube上关于我的艺术表现良好的第一个视频，它被称为，就像，它类似于“表现得很差也没关系”，老实说，这是一个非常深刻的陈述，你随着年龄增长会意识到，表现得很差，我觉得我们在这一集中谈论了很多关于控制，然后谈论了很多关于自由的话题。是的，完全正确。这就是我听到的，我听到你说，就像，等等，这段通往让自己在事情上表现得很差的旅程，让你以一种不再像以前那样具有限制性的方式探索旧爱好。是的，我认为这是真的。哦，我们正在发现主题，我们真的发现了一些好的主题，我喜欢心理学，我有一个小主题可以挖掘。
it and be bad and so I think that's what like the first video that did like well about my art on YouTube was it was called like it was something like it's okay to be bad honestly a very profound statement that you realize the older you get of just like being bad is I feel like we've talked a lot about control and then a lot about freedom in this episode yeah totally and this is what I'm hearing I'm hearing you'd be like wait like this journey towards just letting yourself be bad at things letting yourself explore old hobbies in a way that doesn't sound as like restrictive anymore as it probably was at times yeah I think that's true ooh we're finding we're finding themes here we're really finding some good themes I love a psycho I have a little theme to like digging
我有一个关于你的最后一个问题。这是一个我们，我本来要问你关于搬到伦敦的问题。实际上，让我问你一下。好的。其他人可以调走。这是一个关于我的问题，因为我刚搬到伦敦，你如何享受它？因为我真的在为此挣扎。我相信很多人搬到城市后会说，我有这个关于它会是什么样子的浪漫想法，但事实并非如此。所以作为一个刚搬到伦敦的人，我，即我，或者某个听众。是的。你会有什么建议？你会说你正在为什么而挣扎？你觉得社交情况是一个问题吗？我非常幸运。我很快就交到了很多朋友。这其实很有趣。我出去，就像，
into. I have one final question for you. This is a question that we, I was going to ask you about moving to London. Actually, let me ask you about it. Okay. Everybody else can tune out. This is a me question because I have just moved to London and how do you enjoy it? Because I'm really struggling with it. And I'm sure a lot of people have moved to cities and been like, I have this whole romantic idea of what this was going to be and it's not that. So somebody who's just moved to London, I, e. me or somebody listening. Yeah. What's like some advice that you would have? What would you say is what are you struggling with? Do you feel like the social situation is a thing? I've gotten so lucky. I've made so many friends really quickly. It's actually funny. I like went out and was like,
我是一个非常务实的人，我已经在那里待了一两个月了，我想，太好了。所以我需要交一些朋友。所以我在一个周末预订了大约七个交友活动，就在一个周末交到了所有的朋友。现在我感觉，准备好了。所以，显然，但我认为这只是意识到这并不是我想象的那样，并与此达成和解。是的。你认为它会是什么样子？我想我喜欢它是如何，哦，桌子转了。我，哦，不，我想我以为它会更令人兴奋，更忙碌，更容易。而且我，你知道我想什么，我不认为这个城市这么大。对。我以为事情会更近。也许这就是原因，我当时想，哦，会有很多机会做事情。就像，确实有。但它需要你两个小时。
I'm a very practical person and I had been here for a month or two and I was like, great. So I need to make some friends. So I booked like seven like friendship making activities in one weekend and just made all my friends on one weekend. And now I'm like, good. to go. So, and obviously, but I think it's just like realizing this isn't what I thought it was going to be and like making peace with that. Yeah. What did you think it was going to be? I think I love how, oh, to the tables. I'll, oh, no, I think that I thought it was going to be a lot more like exciting and go, go, go and like, easy. And I, you know what I think I thought, I didn't think the city was this big. Right. I thought that things were going to be closer. And maybe that's what it is where I was like, oh, there's going to be so many opportunities to do things. It's like, there are. But it takes you two hours.
你实际上不能因为通勤而做所有事情。是的，是的，你没说错。悉尼不是那样吗？哦，不，不，不。好吧，我也，就像，永远不会过桥。所以，就像，悉尼有两个侧面。它曾经是，技术上有三个。但我不知道。
you actually can't do it all because of a commute. Yeah, yeah, you're not wrong. Is that not how Sydney is? Oh, no, no, no. Well, also, I, like, would never go over the bridge. So, like, there's two sides of Sydney. It was, like, three, technically. But I don't know.
就像，我住在哪里，就像，在它的中心。是的。不，悉尼根本不是那样。但你知道有趣的是，即使你说，就像，我在悉尼不过桥。这就是你对伦敦的了解。真的吗？是的，在三四个月内。
Like, I lived where, like, in the heart of it. Yeah. No, it's not how Sydney is like at all. But you know what's funny is even you saying, like, I don't go over the bridge in Sydney. That is the knowledge that you will have of London. Really? Yeah, in, like, three or four months.
你会说，哦，我不去。我不去那里，因为我不喜欢那里的交通连接。就像，你知道我的意思吗？就像，你会有时刻，你会了解这个城市。这只是需要，你知道，就像你必须通过体验它来在城市中刻下你的小印记，直到你达到理解它的纹理并能弄清楚你要去哪里的地步。哦，我喜欢那个。是的。那是一个非常美丽的类比。
You'll be like, oh, I don't go to. I don't go there because I don't like my connections there. Like, you know what I mean? Like, you will have moments where you go, you'll know the city. It just takes, you know, it's like you have to carve your little mark in the city by experiencing it until you get to the point where you understand the grooves and you can like figure out where you're going. Oh, I love that. Yeah. That's a really beautiful analogy.
好吧，就像，你知道，你的路径，你最终去得最多的地方，就是我的河流流经的地方。是的，完全正确。是的。但我发现它还可以。我想，以一种和你类似的方式，我很快就交到了朋友，因为我丈夫是我来伦敦的全部原因。就像，我们异地恋了很多年很多年。我们开始约会时我大概19岁，他20、21岁。比我大一点。
Well, it's like, you know, your pathways where you end up like going the most is kind of where my like river runs. Yeah, totally. Yeah. But I found it okay. I think, like, in a similar way to you, I found my friends really quickly because my husband was the entire reason I came to London. Like, we were long distance for years and years and years. And we started dating when I was 19, I want to say, and he was 20, 21. A little older than me.
我能说什么呢？喜欢老男人。但因为他是伦敦人，我基本上可以接入他整个朋友圈。我丈夫真的很酷的一点是，我是以最积极的方式说这个。他就像，艾利先生。我们就像，是的，就像我们整个朋友圈都是酷儿。所以这真的很酷。所以，我不知道，从阿肯色州小石城来到这里，我当时受到如此多的保护，然后住在洛杉矶，我的思想稍微扩展了一点。
What can I say? Love an old woman. But because he is from London, I basically kind of got to plug into his whole friend group. And what's really cool about my husband is that he is like, I mean this in like the most positive way. He's like, Mr. Alley. We're like, yeah, like our entire friend group is queer people. So that was really cool. So like, I don't know, coming from Litter Rock, Arkansas where I was like so sheltered to then be living in Los Angeles where like my mind was expanding a little bit.
然后搬到伦敦，处于酷人的中心，这真是太不同了。我不知道。我想我真的很喜欢搬到这里，因为我只是在吸收很多东西。是的。这就是我需要做的。我需要走出去。我确实找到了很棒的人，但我认为我需要专注于体验这个城市所能提供的东西。是的。完全正确。而且这就像它是一个巨大的视野扩展器。是的。而且我也认为人们非常锁定在他们的行政区。就像我注意到了这一点。就像，很大程度上。就像我，我是一个大，就像，我曾经住在伦敦西南部，这很棒，但它就像最沉睡的
And then moving to London and being like in the epicenter of like just cool people was just such a different. I don't know. I think I really liked moving here because it was I was just absorbing. so much. Yeah. This is what I need to do. I need to get out there. I definitely found great people, but I think I need to like focus on experiencing the city for what it has to offer. Yeah. Totally. And that being like it's a big horizon expander. Yeah. And I also think that people are very locked in on their boroughs. Like I have noticed this. Like big time. Like I'm like, I'm a big like, like, I used to live in southwest London, which was great, but it's like the sleepiest
世界上所有的地方。那是在哪里？什么，给我一个郊区？它就像在哈默史密斯附近。就像诺丁山会是西南部。就像你知道我的意思吗？就像那种区域，就像我的很多朋友。我正在很好地掌握我的地理。是的。是的。西。
place in the entire world. Where is that? What's, give me a suburb? It's like near Hammersmith. Like Notting Hill would be like Southwest. Like you know what I mean? Like that kind of like area like a lot of my friends. I'm getting my geography well. Yeah. Yeah. West.
西区总体上。我觉得它现在非常沉睡。但就像，不讨厌西区。西区人。是的。但后来我并没有真正探索很多其他行政区。然后我，是的，只是花了更多时间在东部和北部，还有一点时间在南部。就像扩展我的视野。
West in general. I feel like it's just like very sleepy now. But like no hate to West. Westies. Yeah. But then like I hadn't really explored a lot of the other boroughs. And then I yeah, have just been spending a lot more time kind of like east and north and a little bit of time in south. Kind of like expanding my horizons.
但问题是。就像你刚到这里。我刚开始那样做。而且我已经来回这里大约10年了。所以我有什么借口？我不知道。我需要加入其中。是的。
But here's the thing. Like you just got here. I just started doing that. And I've been coming back and forth here for like 10 years. So what excuse do I have? I don't know. I need to get in on it. Yeah.
这就像更明智的。你是更明智版本的我。我不知道。但不，就像我需要，我想我需要大口咬下伦敦。是的。好吧，我们可以一起做。我们在东区吃晚饭。是的。
This is like the wiser. You were the wiser version of me. I don't know about that. But no, but like I need to, I need to take a big abide of London, I think. Yeah. Well, we can do that together. We'll get dinner in the east. Yes.
是的。我总是试图把人们拉向不同的方向。就像我所有的朋友，顺便说一下，我在东区。我当时想，是的。我当时想，我做了什么？因为我住在西北部。是的，是的。喜欢我住的地方。
Yeah. I'm always trying to like pull people in different directions. Like all my friends, I'm in the east, by the way. And I'm like, yeah. And I'm like, what have I done? Because I live in like the northwest. Yeah, yeah. love where I live.
但我所有的邻居要么非常老，要么非常有名。对。而我们两者都不是。所以就像我觉得他们有时很困惑为什么我们在那里。完全正确。我不认为我见过任何住在我们社区的人年龄在35岁以下。对，对，对，对，对。或者收入水平低于3500万。
But all my neighbors are either very old or very famous. Right. And we are neither of those things. So it's like I think they're sometimes confused as to why we are there. Totally. I don't think I've met anybody who lives in my neighborhood who's under the age of 35. Right, right, right, right, right. Or under like the income level of 35 million.
对，对，对，对。我觉得我们只是搞砸了。但我们也有这个真正，公寓技术上是不适合居住的。就像，我不认为你注定要住在那里。我喜欢伦敦的这一点。有时它就像，是的，我们只是住在这种老鼠洞里。是的。就像，是的，我们住在一个桶里。
Right, right, right, right. And I feel like we just kind of messed up. But also we have like this really apartment that is technically not live. Like, I don't really think you're meant to live there. I love that about London. And sometimes it's just like, yeah, we just live in this like rat hole. Yeah. Like, yeah, we live in a bucket.
而且，它要3000英镑。但就像，他们让我们住。我记得我们搬进去时，我问房东。我当时想，如果发生火灾怎么办？他说，好吧，屋顶上应该有个梯子。屋顶上应该有个梯子。我不能，但我们不知道那在哪里。就像，它在哪里？
And like, it's 3,000 pounds. But like, they let us. I remember Al Landl when we moved in. I was like, so what happens if there's a fire? He's like, well, there should be a ladder on the roof. There should be a ladder on the roof. I can't, but we don't know where that is. Like, where is it?
太棒了。是的。总之。是的。太棒了。不，那真是太典型了。但，但不，你得过来和我一起在我那边的城镇闲逛。成交。
Awesome. Yeah. Anyway. Yes. Awesome. No, that's like such a thing. But, but no, you'll have to come hang out with me over on my side of town. Done.
其他地方，看看也许有30岁以下的人。我不认为他们存在于这里。他们不存在吗？我不知道。不幸的是，我不会支持那个统计数据，但我会找到能做到的人。我觉得30岁是新的25岁。嘿，谢谢，宝贝。我一直对我朋友这么说。
elsewhere and see maybe someone under the age of 30. I don't think they exist here. Do they not? I don't know. Unfortunately, I'm not going to hold up that statistic, but I'll find someone who can. I feel like 30 is the new 25. Hey, thanks, babe. I've been saying that to my friends.
谢谢。骄傲就像爱。你能在心里感觉到它。iHeart Radio。加拿大排名第一的广播和播客流媒体应用程序，包括iHeart Pride Canada，你最喜欢的热门歌曲和必备派对金曲，加上个性化和策划的播放列表，如“Back in the Day Pride”。聚在一起，庆祝爱。
Thanks. Pride is like love. You feel it in your heart. IR. Radio. Canada's number one streaming app for radio and podcasts, including IHart Pride Canada, your favorite hits and must have party bangers, plus personalized and curated Playlists like back in the day pride. Come together, celebrate love.
随身携带骄傲。随时随地。只需让你的智能音箱播放iHeart Pride Canada。在手机上流媒体播放，或立即在iHeartRadio.ca收听。那一刻，感觉它永远在持续。我不认为我会活下来。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。
Take pride with you. Anytime, anywhere. Just ask your smart speaker to play IHart Pride Canada. Stream us on your phone or listen now at iHeartRadio.ca. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes.
它们变黑了。它把我吓坏了。那是你的第一个谋杀案？是的，先生。可以说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件吗？是的，先生。强奸和谋杀一个孩子。
They turned black. It scared the hell out of it. me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fair to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape and murder for a child.
就像最糟糕的情况一样。我想是这样。邪恶，醒醒。我就是那个目睹了克雷维特和德皮波谋杀案的人。安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后毫无悔意，表现得泰然自若。我说，我没有罪。我会把这个秘密带进坟墓。
Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevent and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave.
请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《魔鬼的采石场》。想要收听无广告版《魔鬼的采石场》并获取独家内容，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅“Love for Good Plus”。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》的主持人。我们将与世界上最迷人的人进行有意义的对话，比如女演员奥利维亚·穆恩分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战时说：“我经历过乳腺癌，后来又帮助我母亲对抗乳腺癌，
Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer,
那更困难。有很多人了解产后抑郁症。我当时对产后焦虑毫无准备。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》。这是它的一部分，这是一种兴奋，因为他们的新星是哈维尔·T·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我视为足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。从我出生起，每一天我都在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情绪共处。
and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. It is part of it's a excitement because their new star is Javier T. Tarito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions. ever since I was born.
我仍然有很多问题。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何应对被取消？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨？
And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa?
从日常平凡到深邃非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行深度交谈。在这里展现脆弱。阴谋论被摆上台面，目标和人生经验被分享。此生有着完美的秩序，一切都只是……等等我，我将……但我将去建立联系。
From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends. Where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. This life has an order perfect and all is just. Wait me, I'm going to pressur me, but me will go to be going to connect.
“小豌豆”。哦，哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯，与iHeart Radio一起，我们将让平凡变得非凡。保持关注。他是个天才。哇。请在iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。基思·吉安曼卡看起来像个温文尔雅的郊区父亲，但私下里，他变成了另一个人，一个擅长伪装并开始犯罪狂潮的人。
The Chicharito. Oh, Javier, Chicharito-Landes, and together with Aihar Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It's a carac. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Keith Gianmanca seemed like a mild-mannered suburban dad, but secretly, he became someone else, a master of disguise who went on a crime spree.
当时，这看起来是个疯狂的想法吗？看起来非常疯狂。但我感到如此绝望，以至于我觉得这是最快、最简单的出路。你有没有让自己去想如果事情搞砸了会怎样，或者那会是什么样子？不，我不想预示那种结果。我试图预示成功。每个家庭都有秘密。但当你发现你的父亲一直过着双重生活时会发生什么？
At the time, did it seem like a crazy idea? It seemed very crazy. But I felt so desperate that I felt it was the quickest, easiest way out. Did you allow yourself to think about how it could go wrong and what that might look like? No, I didn't want to manifest that. I was trying to manifest success. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life?
那不是一个无辜者的眼神。这将永远改变我的生活和家庭动态，因为我现实中之前存在的一切现在都不真实了。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Deep Cover: The Family Man》。最后一个问题，我们也会问播客的每一位嘉宾，那就是你在20多岁时学到的最大教训是什么？哦，我想，你知道吗？
That is not the look of an innocent man. This is going to change my life and my family dynamic forever, because everything that had existed prior in my reality is now untrue. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Final question we also have every single guest. on the podcast, which is what is the biggest lesson that you have learned in your 20s? Ooh, I think, you know what?
再一次，我想这回到了我们一直在谈论的一切。但我认为我学到的最大教训是，人们并没有真正那样看着我。你知道我的意思吗？每个人都太沉迷于自己了。而且我想，我一直非常担心，就像一个在高中被欺负的人，我总是会有点提防，或者总是说错话，或者总是有点尴尬。然后我意识到，实际上没有人，真的没有人关心。这在很多方面都非常自由。
Again, I think it comes back to everything we've been talking about. But I think the biggest lesson I learned was that people aren't really looking at me like that. You know what I mean? Everyone's like so obsessed with themselves. And I think like I was so worried all the time, like, as someone who was like bullied in high school that I was like going to be always kind of watching my back. or like always saying the wrong thing or always being kind of awkward. And then I realized like actually no one, literally no one cares. And that was very freeing in so many ways.
就像我认为我有很多内疚感和负面情绪，仅仅是因为作为一个被感知的人。甚至不是像社交媒体那样的感知，而只是人际感知。我想我实际上比人们在现实中对我的看法更不在乎人们在网上对我的看法。但我认为我已经完全摆脱了这一点。天哪，我希望你能把那种感觉装进瓶子里分发出去。我太想了。是的。就像我有时会为20多岁的人考虑这一点，因为我当时想，
Like I think I had a lot of like guilt and like negative feelings around just like being a person in being perceived. Not even like a social media perception, but just like interpersonal perception. I think I actually cared less about what people thought about me online than people think about me in person. But I think I've just completely like ex-nade that. God, I wish you could bottle that feeling and pass it out. I want to so badly. Yeah. Like I think about that sometimes for like people in their early 20s because I'm like,
哦，女孩。是的。我为你感到难过。就像20多岁出头的女性，我不认为我会再回到21岁。你付钱给我也不行。不，除非我有现在的头脑，我可以像，这些狗屁都不重要。是的。
oh, girl. Yeah. I feel so bad for you. Like women in their young, like early 20s, like I don't think I would ever go back to being 21. You could not pay me. No, unless I had my brain now and I could be like, none of this shit matters. Yes.
我会没事的。我经常在约会时想到这一点。我当时想，天哪，我希望我能像20岁时那样约会。显然，我爱我在一起的人。抱歉。是的。我一生的挚爱。是的。但我有时想，我希望我有现在的头脑，能在那时约会并真正享受乐趣，因为直到我遇到我男朋友之前，我从未在约会中获得乐趣。完全正确。我完全知道你的意思。我有同样的感觉。这有点像那个关于，嗯，西尔维娅·普拉斯的无花果树。我们前几天刚做了一集关于那个的节目。是的。这很相似，
I'd be fine. I think about that with dating. the time. I'm like, brick, I wish I could be dating as like a 20 year old. Obviously, I love who I'm with. Sorry. Yeah. My beautiful boyfriend. Yes. Love of my life. But like, sometimes I'm like, I wish that I had the brain that I have now and could have dated back then and actually had fun because I've never had fun dating until I met my boyfriend. Totally. I totally know what you mean. I feel the same way. It's kind of that whole thing about like, um, what's this Sylvia Plath fig tree. We literally just did an episode on that the other day. Yeah. It's similar where it's,
你知道，当你谈论约会时，没那么令人沮丧。但就像，是的，我同意。仅仅能够享受事物，因为你知道，它并不重要。但你知道吗，那也是事后诸葛亮。就像，你知道。完全正确。我现在仍然会对事情感到紧张和焦虑。这并不意味着，就像，五年后我不会像，我希望我在30岁时只是不在乎。是的。
you know, a little less depressing when you're talking about dating. But like, it would just, yeah, I agree. Just being able to enjoy stuff because you know, like, it doesn't matter. But you know what, that's also hindsight. Like, you know. Exactly. I can still be nervous and, like, anxious about things now. It doesn't mean that, like, in five years I'm not going to be like, I wish I just didn't care when I was 30. Yeah.
我可能仍然会那样说，你知道吗？这回到了你之前说的，变老是一种特权。我看着，比如，我的妈妈，还有我的阿姨们。而且我总是认为拥有比你大几岁的朋友也很重要。是的。而且我也拥有比你大几十岁的朋友，因为看起来它只会变得越来越好。看起来太有趣了。是的。视角能做的事情太疯狂了。就像当你遇到一个仍然很酷、看起来很棒、过着最好生活的人，而他们比你大20岁时。
I probably will still say that, you know? It brings back to that thing you said before of, like, getting older is, like, such a privilege. And I look at, like, my mom, for example, and, like, my aunts. And I always think it's so important to have friends who are a few years older than you as well. Yeah. And I also a few decades older than you because it just seems like it gets better and better. better. It looks so much fun. Yeah. Crazy what perspective can do. Like when you meet someone who's like still rocking it and looking so cool and like doing like the best kind of life and they're like 20
我在寻找一些白发。我知道。如果它发生了，我会全白。我准备好了。是的。我准备好了。我知道，就像，你还记得那个节目吗，有一个叫斯泰西·伦敦的女人，她是TLC的造型师。那是美国的一个节目，但她，你以后需要查查她。她有这个节目。它叫《What Not to Wear》。它不太好。它没能经受住时间的考验。有很多关于 flattering 或 unflattering，或者 frumpy 或 not frumpy 的讨论，就像不太好的身体讨论。但她从我们这个年龄到40多岁，头发里有一缕最棒的灰色。而且她仍然保持着它。她看起来太酷了。是的。这将是新的趋势。
years older than you. I'm looking for some gray hair. I know. I'm going to do full gray if it happens. I'm down to clown. Yeah. I'm so down to clown. I know like, do you remember that show is called there was a there was a woman named Stacey London who was like a stylist on the TLC. It was like a thing in America, but she, you need to look her up later. She had this show. It was called What Not to Wear. And it was not great. It didn't age well. It was a lot of things being flattering or unflattering or frumpy or not frumpy, like not great body discussions happening. But she had the most fabulous streak of gray in her hair from when she was like at like our age into her 40s. And she still like maintains it. And she looks so cool. Yeah. This is going to be the new trend.
我认为白发将是未来的趋势。是的。因为它是一个标志，就像是，它是完全自我接纳的标志，也是对衰老宣传的抵制。100%。是的。我认为这也是，能够移动你的脸也是一样。你知道吗？是的。
I think gray hair is going to be where it's at. Yeah. Because it's a sign of like being, it's a sign of total self-acceptance and like push back against like the aging propaganda. 100%. Yeah. I think that's also like being able to move your face is the same thing. You know? Yeah.
好吧，非常感谢你来参加播客。希望你玩得开心。我玩得很开心。谢谢你邀请我。我真的很喜欢这次聊天。是的。如果你想让我再来，请告诉我。是的，我知道。
Well, thank you so much for coming on the podcast. I hope you had a great time. I did. Thank you for having me. I really enjoyed this chat. Yeah. Let me know if you ever want me back. Yeah, I know.
好吧，也许人们会像。希望他们认为我们有很好的氛围。是的。人们在哪里可以找到你？你现在在你的职业生涯和生活中有什么让你感到非常兴奋的事情吗？你想让人们知道的。是的。好吧，我像往常一样在我的所有社交媒体上。
Well, maybe people are going to be like. And hopefully they think we have a good vibe. Yeah. Where can people find you? And what is something you're really excited about going on in your career in your life right now? You want people to know about. Yeah. Well, I'm on all my socials as per yuge.
我还刚刚发布了一个与Lisa Says Gar的合作系列，如果你在Netflix上观看，你正穿着它。你走进来时，我当时想，那件衣服太棒了。是的。而且你画了那个。是的。这是我的画。我想饱和度被调高了一点。但是的，我做了一个花田的三联画，有点像莫奈。
I also just released a collection with Lisa Says Gar, which you are wearing if you're watching on Netflix. Literally you walked in and I was like, that's that shot is phenomenal. Yeah. And you painted that. Yeah. This is my painting. I think the saturation's been bumped up a little bit. But yeah, I did a trip deck of blossoms in a field, kind of like all-a Monet.
这是我的莫奈复制品，远不如原作好。不幸的是，他算是一位大师。所以这是我的一种尝试。但它做成了一件很棒的衬衫。确实。它确实。好吧，我会让人们去看看。他们可以在社交媒体上找到Join。
It was my Monet copy, not nearly as good. Unfortunately, he's kind of a master. So that's kind of my attempt of it. But it made a fabulous shirt. It does. It actually does. Okay, I'm going to get people to check that out. They can find join on socials.
是的。一如既往，伙计们，非常感谢你们的收听。你也可以在下面的剧集描述中找到《20多岁的心理学》的社交媒体。如果你想在Substack、Instagram上关注我们，所有这些东西。我觉得每一集，我想。我给你一个更长的列表，但都在下面。当然，你也可以通过关注描述中的链接找到Arden并查看她的更多动态。但直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔。
Yeah. As always, guys, thank you so much for listening. You can also find the psychology of your 20s on socials in the episode description down below. If you want to follow us on substack, Instagram, all those things. I feel like every single episode, I think. I give you a longer list, but it's all down below. And of course, you can also find Arden and see more of what she's up to by following the links in the description. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself.
我们很快就会再谈。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变黑了。它把我吓坏了。邪恶，醒醒。我就是那个目睹了克雷维特和德皮波谋杀案的人。安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后毫无悔意，表现得泰然自若。我说，我没有罪。我会把这个秘密带进坟墓。
We will talk very, very soon. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevecette and de Pitpo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief.
我们很快就会再谈。那双眼睛里空无一物。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。邪恶，醒醒。我是那个亲眼目睹了Crevecette和de Pitpo谋杀案的人。Anthony DePippo没有表现出任何悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得泰然自若。我说，我没有罪。我会带着这个秘密进坟墓。
Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential, and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats.
请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《骨谷的魔鬼采石场》。快乐至关重要，却也难以捉摸。但现在，有一种令人兴奋的新方式可以开启您通往更快乐生活的旅程。《快乐101》，这是一档由我霍达·科特比主持的新播客。如果您渴望获得灵感来最大化您的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的节目。
Open your free I-Heart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda-Kotty is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born.
打开您免费的iHeart Radio应用程序，搜索《快乐101》并立即收听。《快乐101》由CVS呈现。每个人都视我为一名足球运动员，但首先，我是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何面对问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。
This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tchariot-O-R-Nandes, and listen to Learning to Be Human on I-Hard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad
这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。只是关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·查里奥特-奥-埃尔南德斯，请在iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。每个家庭都有自己的秘密。但当你发现你的父亲
has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation. I felt it was what I had to do. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. For years, the unhoused have been presented as a monolith in mainstream media. Weedian House is a podcast that's changing the narrative. I'm Theo Henderson, and I created the show why I was unhoused on the streets of Los Angeles.
一直过着双重生活时会发生什么？那看起来不像是一个无辜的人。每个人都在对我撒谎吗？我感到如此绝望。我觉得这是我必须做的事。请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《深度掩护：顾家男人》。多年来，无家可归者在主流媒体中一直被呈现为一个单一的群体。《Weedian House》是一档正在改变这种叙事的播客。我是西奥·亨德森，我在洛杉矶街头无家可归时创办了这个节目。
We've grown into a two-time Webby Award-winning podcast, the only podcast that shares unhoused stories and news from the unhoused perspective. Listen to Wey &House on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们已经成长为一档两度获得威比奖的播客，也是唯一一档从无家可归者视角分享无家可归者故事和新闻的播客。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Wey & House》。这是一个iHeart播客，保证由人类制作。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。